Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Elf Spieltage sind absolviert in der 2. Männer-Bundesliga. Und ach, es ist schon wieder so einiges passiert. Wir müssen darüber sprechen. Jetzt hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Es ist wieder soweit. Wir wollen auf die 2. Männer-Bundesliga blicken. Da ist, wie gerade schon so gesagt, mal wieder ein bisschen Gesprächsbedarf vorhanden. Und deshalb freue ich mich sehr, dass ihr hier eingeschaltet habt. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter. Und ich begrüße jetzt bei mir zwei Stimmen, die ihr aus der 2. Liga, also 2. Männer-Liga-Podcast-Welt schon kennen könntet. Zum einen Tim Ecksteen. Er ist Sportjournalist. Er ist beim Millern-Ton zu hören. Er ist auf Twitter der Ed-Tim-Ecksteen. Also nicht so wahnsinnig kreativ, aber umso mehr informativ in seinen Beiträgen. Schön, dass du hier bist, Tim.
Ja, moin, Max. Danke für die Einladung. Also kreativ, sagst du vielleicht, er ist jetzt nicht sonderlich kreativ, aber ich habe eigentlich einen anderen Nachnamen. Das geht aber nur ganz interne Leute was an.
Ich sehe schon. Da habe ich dich sehr unterschätzt und unter Wert verkauft. Also schön, dass du hier bist und mir diese freche Anmaut offenbar verziehen hast.
Gleich um die Ohren gehauen, das Ding.
So soll es aber auch sein. Und so darf das jetzt auch gleich Fadi Keblawi machen. Er ist Redakteur bei den Nürnberger Nachrichten. Er ist auch zu hören im Club-Podcast K-Dep. Auf Twitter ist er der Ad-Go-Punk-Hurst. Ich hoffe, ich habe das richtig ausgesprochen. Fadi, schön, dass du hier im Rasenfunk bist.
Alles richtig ausgesprochen, richtige Nachname. Ich bin begeistert.
Ja, Wahnsinn. Also wirklich. Da müssen wir jetzt direkt weiter machen mit dem Blick auf diese Liga. Diese Sendung machen wir es wieder ein bisschen so wie zuletzt, denn ihr habt euch geäußert als Feedback auf den letzten Kurzpass zur zweiten Liga, dass euch die Variante mit den Vereinen dann doch ein bisschen lieber war als die mit den Spielen. Deswegen machen wir das natürlich so. Euer Wunsch ist unser Gehör. Kann man das so sagen? Ist egal. Wir machen einfach direkt los. Die Schwerpunkte werden wir heute legen auf dem FC St. Pauli und dem 1. FC Nürnberg. Das habt ihr euch schon selbst gedacht. Wir beginnen jetzt aber und sprechen mal kurz über den HSV, denn der thront immer noch an der Tabellenspitze, hat erst zweimal verloren, achtmal gewinnen können, ist damit das Team mit den meisten Siegen, acht aus elf Spielen gewonnen. Das ist auch wirklich nicht so schlecht. Erst sieben Tore kassiert, 17 geschossen, 25 Punkte. Und ja, Tim, die Frage muss jetzt natürlich zuerst an dich gehen. Jetzt am Wochenende zwar ein Unentschieden, also eine leichte Delle, aber der Nachbar vom FC St. Pauli, der steht gerade nicht so schlecht da. Warum denn?
Ja, das kann ich so unterschreiben. Das ist ja tatsächlich schon das übliche Herbstgebaren des HSV, so weit oben zu stehen in der Tabelle zu der Zeit. Jetzt kommen sie ja ans Millantor in drei Tagen und dann wollen wir mal sehen, was da passiert. Der HSV steht gut, hat vor allem die beste Abwehr der Liga. Und ehrlich gesagt, wenn ich mir die Expected Goals mal anschaue, dann kann ich gar nicht so ganz genau erklären, warum. Weil sie eigentlich ja fast doppelt so viele Expected Goals ergänzt haben, wie sie Gegentore gefangen haben. Haben aber die beste Abwehr der Liga. Ich wage da, zu bezweifeln anhand der Statistik, dass das so bleibt. Und trotzdem muss man sagen, dass der HSV spielerisch vielleicht sogar noch mal ein ganzes Stück weiter nach vorne gekommen ist, als in der letzten Saison. Also der Fußball ist tatsächlich ziemlich gut geworden. Dieser Walther Ball, der wurde ja durchaus schon ein bisschen weiterentwickelt. Der bleibt auch zu einer Art, wie soll ich sagen, einer Art Mysterium. Und diese flexible Viererkette, die sie da hinten haben, mit diesen krassen Rotationen, das hat man letztes Jahr, Anfang der letzten Saison, da sind sie nämlich ausnahmsweise mal nicht ganz so gut gestartet. Da hat man schon gemerkt, dass es da ja so ein, zwei Probleme gibt in der Abstimmung. Jetzt haben sie tatsächlich die Spieler vielleicht auch so weit bekommen, dass das jetzt viel besser funktioniert und sie eben den Aufwand vielleicht sogar ein bisschen zurückfahren können. Interessant finde ich, wenn man sich anschaut, wie der HSV spielt, da erkennt man, dass sie viele progressive Läufe ziehen. Wenn man sich in die White-Scout-Statistiken mal so ein bisschen einarbeitet – progressive Läufe – heißt, dass sie eben mit Ball am Fuß wahnsinnig viele Meter oder sehr viele Meter zum gegnerischen Tor überbrücken. Das machen sie viel mehr als mit progressiven Pässen. Und da sieht man eben so ein bisschen die Spielweise des HSV. Es ist ja letztendlich der Walther Ball, den sie haben. Da rotiert ja die hintere Viererkette. Da taucht dann auf einmal der Rechtsverteidiger auf der linken Seite auf. Da schiebt dann auf einmal der halbrechte Achter. Der schiebt auf einmal da einen linken Halbraum rein oder ganz links hinten in die Kette. Positionen werden aufgelöst. Heuer Fernandes dahinter ist wahnsinnig aktiv, ist wahnsinnig weit vorne. Und letztendlich, wenn man das runterbricht auf das, was sie damit machen wollen, dann geht es eigentlich fast nur darum, die Außenposition freizuspielen. Da Dom P den neuen linksaußen, Yata auf der rechten Seite, Rensford-Jeboah Königsdorfer ist mit Sicherheit einer der talentiertesten Außenspieler der 2. Liga. Darum geht es, die freizuspielen, die in direkte Duelle zu bekommen. Das ist tatsächlich ein sehr gewagtes Stilmittel, auch ziemlich risikoreich, aber sieben Gegentore sagen denen ja schon, die kriegen das ganz gut hin, ganz gut hinten dicht. Allerdings, wie gesagt, Expected Goals Against liegt fast bei 14. Wenn man sich das letzte Spiel gegen Kaiserslautern angeschaut hat, da würde ich schon sagen, Anfälligkeit, gerade in Umschaltmomenten, die ist durchaus vorhanden. Kaiserslautern ist natürlich auch der beste Gegner, was so Umschalten angeht. Die haben das auch ziemlich gut drauf. Beim HSV sind sie zu Recht da oben, das kann man schon sagen. Aber defensiv sind sie nicht so stark, wie die Gegentor-Anzahl vermuten lässt.
Das waren jetzt mal einfach drei kompakte Minuten. Ich möchte danach nichts sagen müssen, deswegen sage ich einfach Fadi, hast du noch etwas zu ergänzen?
Tatsächlich nicht. Sie ist die beste Mannschaft der 2. Liga in dieser Saison. Ich glaube, ich auch. Ich habe sie ja hier beim Gastspiel in Nürnberg schon erleben dürfen. Da fand ich sie erstaunlicherweise gar nicht so wild, wie dieser Walter Ball ja oft mal beschrieben wird. Und auch gar nicht so überzeugend. Er hat dann trotzdem noch zu einem einigermaßen entspannten Sieg beim Club gelangt. Aber wenn man sich den Rest der Liga so anguckt, dann muss sich der HSV dieses Jahr schon wieder was sehr Besonderes einfallen lassen, um am Ende Vierter oder Fünfter zu werden. Ich habe so ein bisschen den Verdacht, dass sie am Samstag gegen Karlslautern damit begonnen haben, mit verschossenen Elfmeter und dann noch dem Ausgleich kurz vor Schluss. Also das müsste fürs Frühjahr werden beim HSV. Aber eigentlich müssten sie dieses Jahr mal hoch.
Ja, ich habe mir das Spiel natürlich auch angeschaut am Samstag. Das war, ja, ich finde, auf jeden Fall eins der schönsten Zweitligaspiele in dieser Saison, weil es echt abwechslungsreich war, weil Kaiserslautern auch echt präsent vorne war. Aber da sieht man es eben, dass der HSV hinten durchaus noch schon eine gewisse Anfälligkeit hat. Und ja, ich kann viel zum HSV erzählen, weil das ist halt der nächste Gegner, das FC St. Pauli. Und ich habe gerade, just heute Mittag, die Taktikanalyse des HSV gemacht. Deswegen sprudelte es so aus mir heraus.
Du musst dich nicht dafür rechtfertigen, dass du hier uns das so perfekt beschreibst. Das ist ja super. Gleichzeitig möchte ich aber nur einmal noch kurz einen Hinweis machen, weil ich habe das neulich auch in einem anderen Fußball-Podcast gehört. Ich glaube, es war beim Sportradio 360. Also ja, der HSV spielt sehr gut aktuell. Und man muss jetzt auch gar nicht irgendwelche April-Mythen und so weiter bemühen. Aber es ist halt immer noch sehr eng in der Tabelle. Also 25 Punkte der HSV, 24 Darmstadt, über die wir gleich sprechen werden, 22 Paderborn, Haydn haben damit 20. Danach gibt es einen Cut. Also das kann man so sagen. Aktuell sind es so eher vier Mannschaften. Aber es kann halt noch sehr viel passieren. Also ich wundere mich manchmal so ein bisschen darüber, dass nur weil es so spektakulär aussieht beim HSV und jetzt auch die Ergebnisse aktuell wirklich stimmen, mit kleineren Ausnahmen, dass da schon so wieder so ja fast absolute Tatsachenbehauptungen hingestellt werden. Es ist halt noch nicht mal ein Drittel der Saison vorbei. Deswegen ganz kurze Vorsicht. Aber den HSV-Fans erzähle ich damit sowieso nicht. Die sind ja sowieso aus verschiedensten Gründen ganz, ganz anders gepolt. Und es ist aber ja schön, dass man dem HSV sehr gerne zugucken kann. Die Frage stellt sich dann Fadi, wie gerne guckt man denn dann Darmstadt 98 zu, die auf Rang 2 liegen? Einen Punkt dahinter. Und auch erst einmal verloren haben.
Nach meiner Erfahrung gar nicht. Aber das gilt tatsächlich. Ich werde heute gnadenlos diese Liga bashen. Das gilt wahrscheinlich für alle anderen Mannschaften, die wir auch noch besprechen werden, bis auf ein, zwei Ausnahmen. Auch da hat der Klub vor Kurzem verloren. Sehr deutlich unterlegen. Und trotzdem gab es keine Sekunde dieses Spiels, wo ich mir dachte, wow, Darmstadt muss ich mir nächste Woche unbedingt nochmal anschauen, weil es so erheiternd und kreativ ist. Die mussten sich gegen den Klub nicht besonders anstrengen. Viel Wucht und viel Arbeit. Und dann mal irgendwann ein Tor nach einer Standardsituation. Das hat mich nicht überzeugt. Wie gesagt, gegen den 1. FC Nürnberg mussten sie nicht sehr viel mehr machen. Aber jetzt am Wochenende gegen Düsseldorf sah es jetzt auch nicht berauschend aus. Ich weiß nicht, ob es diese Liga jedes Jahr gibt oder ob ich diese Liga einfach hasse, weil ich hier auf halbem Weg zwischen Trainingsgelände Spielvereinigung Viert und Trainingsgelände 1. FC Nürnberg sitze.
Das ist natürlich auch das Epizentrum der schlechten Laune gerade.
Von beiden Seiten Woche für Woche nur schlechte Nachrichten.
Da ist ja Mordor gegenüber irgendwie teletabilant.
Deshalb mag es sein, dass ich dieser 2. Liga gegenüber etwas voreingenommen bin im Moment. Aber so wirklich überzeugen können mich da echt nur wenige. Ich finde, der ganzen Liga fehlt es ein bisschen an Kreativität und Ideenreichtum und Witz. Aber vielleicht ist es zu viel verlangt von der 2. Fußball-Bundesliga in Deutschland, der Männer.
Also bei Darmstadt stimme ich dir auf jeden Fall zu. Gerade so was die Spielweise angeht, das ist schon ein sehr hohes Level des gewünschten Lieberknechtfußballs, der da gespielt wird. Die sind unfassbar stabil, defensiv, haben auch viel von ihrem Kader auch zusammengehalten. Letztendlich fehlt da ja – jetzt muss ich mal überlegen, dass ich keinen Quatsch erzähle – aber fehlt eigentlich nur Pfeiffer. Und den haben sie ja relativ gut ersetzt bekommen. Und die sind sehr, sehr effizient und entwickeln natürlich, wie du sagst, Fadi, die können eine wahnsinnige Wucht entwickeln, gerade in den ersten Spielminuten immer. Und sind dann aber ziemlich sehr gute Profis darin, so einen Vorsprung auch zu halten. Das, was man ich persönlich dem FC St. Pauli auch gerne mal wünschen würde, diese defensive Kompaktheit, Stabilität, das kriegen sie ziemlich gut hin und stehen da auch oben. Aber gerade was so offensive Spielkultur angeht, da ist das Team, was auf dem dritten Platz momentan ist, was wir ja ein bisschen aussparen heute, doch wesentlich attraktiver.
Das war von mir auch gar kein individueller Vorwurf an Darmstadt. Nur wenn es dann so in der ganzen Liga zum Muster wird, dann finde ich das einfach ein bisschen ermüdend irgendwann.
Ja, ich muss ja dazu sagen, jahrelang, fast ein Jahrzehnt, ich werfe ja Darmstadt bis heute vor, dass sie in die zweite Liga ein Virus gesetzt haben, damals mit Schuster, Dirk Schuster, als sie durchmarschiert sind in die erste Liga, mit diesem Fehler, Vermeidungs- und Hoch- und Weitbring-Sicherheit, und Stroh Engel steht vorne und hinten, stehen wir kompakt und wir gewinnen alles 1-0. Da haben sie die ganze Liga über Jahre so dermaßen verpestet mit. Das werfe ich denen bis heute vor und da bin ich auch echt nachtragend.
Weil das quasi ein Erfolgsrezept damals war? Oder wie meinst du das? Also so, wie sich irgendwie die Rabaschule in der ersten Liga durchgesetzt hat. Wir spielen jetzt nur noch gegen den Ball?
Genau, also letztendlich ist es ja so gewesen, dass Darmstadt aus der 3. Liga hochgekommen ist. Die haben da auch schon so ein Fußball gespielt. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele Spiele die 1-0 gewonnen haben. Der Erfolg hat ihnen vollkommen recht gegeben. Ich würde sagen, wenn ich als Darmstadt-Fan hätte, hätte ich das genauso gut gefunden. Aber es war damals so, dass dieser Fehler-Vermeidungs-Fußball, den Darmstadt gespielt hat, dieses krasse, wir spielen hoch und weit auf Dominic Stroh Engel, später war es Sandro Wagner. Dann hatten sie Marcel Heller auf den Außenpositionen, und da haben sie halt immer Tempo gezogen. Und sonst haben sie eigentlich nur dicht gestanden hinten, alles rausgeköpft und superkompakt gestanden. Das war, ja, wahrscheinlich war damals einfach Darmstadt das Team, was als erstes damit sehr erfolgreich war. Und es wäre so oder so gekommen, dieser Fußball. Aber ich persönlich habe damals den Eindruck gehabt, dass sich nachdem Darmstadt da in der Liga war und einmal damit aufgeräumt hat, sozusagen, damit erfolgreich war, haben sich viele Teams daran orientiert. Und dann wurde die 2. Liga über Jahre, 5, 6 Jahre lang, war das richtig nur Fehler, Vermeidungsfußball war es echt nicht ansehnlich. Und die zarten Pflänzchen, die sich letztes Jahr auch entwickelt haben, auch in Nürnberg zum Beispiel, Fadi, oder auch beim FC St. Pauli, die sind jetzt tatsächlich, ja, verwelken die gerade so ein bisschen leider. Es gab wieder so eine richtige Spielkultur, die sich entwickelt haben, Teams, die mutiger Fußball gespielt haben. Und jetzt inzwischen sehe ich das nicht mehr so ganz. Also wird das schon wieder ein bisschen schwierig. Und ja, Darmstadt bleibt Darmstadt, wie es sinkt und lacht.
Dann nehme ich das zurück, dass das kein konkreter Vorwurf an Darmstadt 98 ist.
Von mir auf jeden Fall.
Schämt euch Darmstadt 98.
Ach du, ich glaube, solange die Tabellen weiter sind, sind die da relativ entspannt. Ich habe es mir mal nachgeguckt. Also in der Passquote zum Beispiel auf Rang 12 in der Liga Darmstadt bei 74 Prozent im Ballbesitz ist man auf Rang – da muss ich jetzt schon runtergucken – also ungefähr ausgeglichen. Das stützt so ein bisschen das, was ihr gesagt habt. Wahrscheinlich würden da jetzt auch die Darmstadt-Fans nicht so wahnsinnig gegen kritisieren. Beziehungsweise wenn, dann dürfen sie sich gerne melden. Dann werden wir das im nächsten Kurzpass nochmal näher aufarbeiten. Stellt sich jetzt natürlich die Frage, bzw. eigentlich habt ihr die Frage, glaube ich, schon beantwortet, oder Tim, wie spielt denn dann der 1. FC Heidenheim, der auf Rang 20 liegt? Also Paterborn, die überspringen wir auf Rang 22, können leider nicht alle Teams hier besprechen. Heidenheim dann auf 4 mit 20 Punkten, anschließend an die oberen 3. Hat sich bei Heidenheim in der letzten Dekade irgendetwas verändert an der Spielweise?
Das ist ja das Schöne bei Heidenheim, wenn man sich die Laufstatistiken anschaut, also Sprints, Anzahl Sprints, intensive Läufe und Laufleistung insgesamt, dann gibt es seit 4 Jahren in der 2. Liga kein anderes Team, was in nur einer dieser Statistiken besser ist als der 1. FC Heidenheim. Ich weiß nicht genau, was die da oben auf der Ostalp, das ist ja das höchst gelegen Stadion im Profifußball, glaube ich sogar, ob das die Höhenluft ist, die sie schnuppern oder so, aber auf jeden Fall ist dieser Fußball-Frank Schmidt der Trainer, der hat das mal irgendwie so erklärt, dass da vielleicht auch so ein bisschen so der Spirit im Team ist und dass das sozusagen das lowest Level, was man erreichen muss, um überhaupt eine Option für eine Startelf oder für Spielenminuten bei Heidenheim zu sein, ist eben diese komplette Bereitschaft, sich läuferisch komplett aufzuopfern, die muss da sein und das finde ich schon spannend bei Heidenheim und die haben ja fast noch im Gegensatz zu Darmstadt, spielen die das halt noch viel krasser, also die haben so ein wahnsinnig vertikales Fußballspiel Das hat sich, wie du richtig sagst, in der letzten Dekade einfach nicht geändert. Auf der einen Seite spielen sie die meisten Pässe, oder vor dem letzten Spiel, da ist es so gewesen, da haben sie die meisten Pässe ins letzte Drittel gespielt und zeitgleich aber auch die meisten Bälle verloren, was einfach dafür spricht, dass die direkt nach Ball gewinnen, mit hohem Risiko nach vorne spielen und darüber versuchen, eben durchzubrechen. Und das spielen sie seit Jahren so, sind seit Jahren das laufstärkste Team der Liga und sind seit Jahren da oben mit dran. Also waren ja schon Relegationsplatz, sind immer irgendwie Fünfter, Sechster, haben immer ein gutes Team, egal welche Spieler weggehen, weil die Spieler, die nachkommen, dann jetzt ist das dieses Jahr ist, dass der Andreas, heißt der glaube ich Bec, ich weiß nicht, ob er Andreas mit Vornamen heißt, der von Ulm aus der Regionalliga kommt und sofort in der 2. Liga performt. Solche Spieler haben die halt auch immer wieder. Adrian Bec. Adrian, ah ja, nicht Andreas, sondern Adrian. Ja, genau, und das ist tatsächlich ziemlich bemerkenswert. Also ein ziemlich bemerkenswerter Fußball und ja, schon beeindruckend, dass die das über Jahre so durchziehen können. Und diese Konstanz, die wünscht man ja anderen Teams auch in gewisser Art und Weise.
Und dann kommt bei Heidenheim natürlich noch dazu, dass es Heidenheim ist. Und ich glaube, auch nach dieser langen Zeit in der 2. Liga und als gehobene 2. Ligamannschaft immer noch nicht von allen so wirklich ernst genommen wird. Ich glaube, ja. Ich habe auch hier in Nürnberg immer den Eindruck, und ich habe das tatsächlich mal Robert Klauß in einer Pressekonferenz in dieser Saison gefragt, dass so die vielleicht oberflächlichen Beobachter immer noch davon ausgehen, dass so Mannschaften wie der Klub, großer Name, Mannschaften wie Heidenheim her spielen, habe ich damals gesagt in dieser Pressekonferenz, was dann Robert Klauß zu einer sehr lustigen Antwort bewogen hatte und das natürlich in dieser 2. Liga niemanden her spielt. In der Folge ist an der Klub häufiger mal hergespielt worden von anderen. Aber ich habe schon den Eindruck, dass Heidenheim auch bei aller Qualität immer noch davon lebt, dass viele Mannschaften erst mal denken, sie gehen als Favorit in die Partie gegen Heidenheim und dann merken, shit ist doch ganz schön anstrengend, gegen die zu spielen und da ist es dann schon zu spät. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen ein oberflächlicher Erklärungsansatz, aber es kommt mir immer so vor. Es geht mir mit Sandhausen ähnlich. Also wo du davor denkst, ja, kennt man eigentlich niemanden und dann triffst du halt auf so eine Büffelmannschaft, die einfach alles wegräumen und am Ende hast du 2-0 verloren und wunderst dich.
Ja, die Büffel. Und gleichzeitig kommt bei Heidenheim ein Element mit dabei, gute Standards, auch in diesem Jahr wieder erfolgreichstes Standard-Team, allerdings geteilter Platz mit Darmstadt, Kaiserslautern und Kiel. Also da gab es jetzt noch, weiß nicht, man dominiert da die Liga nicht, aber es ist immer ein Element bei Heidenheim, das muss man so sagen. Und sie haben auch immer da interessante Varianten. Heidenheim bleibt Heidenheim und gleichzeitig, Fadi, hast du ja schon jetzt die Brücke zu Sandhausen gebaut, die Büffel, die einem da begelgen, und bei denen man dann irgendwie nur zu – also hat mich gewundert, dass du nur zu 2 gesagt hast. Ich dachte, man verliert immer nur zu 1 gegen Sandhausen unter Alois Schwarz. Kannst du das noch ein bisschen ausführen, Fadi? Wir springen jetzt quasi von der Tabellenspitze in den mittleren Bereich bis dann runter in den Keller. Also Sandhausen ist jetzt Rang 11 mit 12 Punkten, haben jetzt eben schon 3 Mal gewonnen, 3 Unentschieden gespielt, 5 Niederlagen. Und diese 12 Punkte hat man mit 12 Toren erzielt. Das stützt ja schon so ein bisschen so deine These. Was müssen wir denn noch wissen zu Sandhausen?
FC Nürnberg in Sandhausen immer mit 2 zu 1 in der Nachspielzeit gewinnt. Das war jetzt die letzten beide Mal so. Also da ist eher nichts mit 1 zu 0 Niederlagen. Wenn man verliert, dann durch 4 Standardsituationen im Heimspiel. Und sonst muss man zu Sandhausen nicht mehr viel mehr wissen, außer Alois Schwarz macht den Fußball, den er kann. Und ist damit so semi-erfolgreich. Hat beim 1. Elfzeit in Nürnberg damals überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Funktioniert jetzt in Sandhausen wieder, weil er anscheinend schon ein ganz okayer Fußball-Trainer ist. Und in Sandhausen natürlich auch wieder die Erwartungshaltungen geringer sind. Und ich glaube, er hatte selber mal, als er dann in Nürnberg war, so formuliert, in Sandhausen hast du die Spieler, die noch nach oben wollen, also die noch nicht denken, sie sind die allergrößten und deshalb bereit sind für seine Art von Arbeitsfußball. Und die hast du halt an anderen Standorten vielleicht dann nicht mehr, wo die Spieler denken, sie können es über technische Fähigkeiten regeln. Aber sonst, Sandhausen, da muss der Tim jetzt ein paar Daten raushauen. Was soll man über Sandhausen sagen?
Ja, also das ist auch nicht verwunderlich, dass du nicht viel über Sandhausen sagen kannst, weil wenn man sich die Aktivität anschaut vor den Toren, also wenn man zum Beispiel sich die Expected Goals, wenn man die aufsummiert, die für und gegen Sandhausen und das in den Spielen mal hochrechnet, dann ist Sandhausen tatsächlich das unattraktivste Team der Liga mit einem Gesamt-XG-Wert von 25, 4. Offensiv die schwächste Offensive nach Expected Goals, defensiv allerdings durchaus im Mittelfeld. Und das spiegelt diesen Fußball-Ligen, die spielen auch relativ gut wieder. Dieser krasse Fokus auf die Defensive, die waren ja quasi schon, wie eigentlich fast jedes Jahr, oder nicht wie jede Saison, aber wie recht häufig, letzte Saison im Winter fast schon abgestiegen. Dann haben sie sich Tom Tribull von Hannover 96 geholt. Und der Typ, ein großes Talent ja immer gewesen, hat sich in Fußball-Deutschland ja auch beim FC St. Pauli nie so richtig durchgesetzt, ist in Hannover ja auch relativ schnell dann durchs Raster gefallen und ist dann in Sandhausen komplett aufgegangen, war der zweikampfaktivste Sechser der 2. Liga oder allgemein der zweikampfaktivste Spieler der 2. Liga mit Abstand und hat dann seinen Teil dazu beigetragen. Jetzt sind ja die Ken Zombie Brüder vereint sozusagen in Sandhausen. Und du hast es sehr gut beschrieben, Fadi. Ich finde dieses Büffel, das passt relativ gut. Eine sehr, sehr, sehr physische Mannschaft, die ganz stark eben aus so einer Defensive rauskommt. Und das ist eben auch das, was Alois Schwarz spielen lassen möchte. Und selten auseinandergespielt wird. Also wirklich absolut unangenehm da zu spielen oder allgemein gegen Sandhausen zu spielen.
Ja, ich glaube, weil es ihnen auch egal ist, um wieder zu diesem Herrspielen zurückzukommen, wenn sie mal ein bisschen hergespielt werden. War am Wochenende ja ähnlich, da kommt Magdeburg. Und die einen der interessanteren Ansätze in dieser 2. Liga fußballerisch verfolgen und darf sich mal so eine Halbzeit austoben. Und dann schießt Sandhausen so ein Billo-Tor, wobei das, glaube ich, sogar ganz schön war. Und dann gewinnt Sandhausen das Spiel. Also, das ist ein zynischer Fußball. Was man cooler an ihnen finden kann, ist, glaube ich, dass ihnen die Meinung der anderen wirklich vollkommen egal ist.
Ja, irgendwie, das zieht sich bei Sandhausen so ein bisschen durch. Also, Sandhausen hat gemeinsam mit Kaiserslautern Eintracht Braunspijk mit weitem Abstand den wenigsten Ballbesitz pro Spiel. Alle drei liegen bei 39 Prozent. Also, bei Lautern kann man gerade noch auf 40 aufrunden, bei Sandhausen und Braunspijk definitiv nicht mehr. Das ist 39 Prozent. Und die Passquoten sind auch wirklich nicht überragend. Also, Sandhausen hat eine 68-prozentige Passquote. Das ist die schlechteste der Liga, weil man will ja gar nicht mit Ballzirkulationen und Passstaffetten irgendwie ins gegnerische Drittel kommen. Also, das ist Sandhausen, wie wir es kennen und lieben. 12 Punkte sind es aktuell. Das sind jetzt 2 Punkte. Vorsprung aktuell auf den Relegationsplatz. Wird vermutlich noch eine ganze Weile in dieser Tabellenregion weitergehen für Sandhausen. Und das überrascht ja dann auch niemanden und ist Teil der Beauty of Sandhausen, würde ich fast schon behaupten. Ähnlich sieht es ganz sicher bei Eintracht Braunschweig aus. Die liegen einen Platz dahinter und sind punktgleich aktuell mit Sandhausen. Eintracht Braunschweig, 3 Unentschieden, 3 Siege, 5 Niederlagen. Exakt die identische Bilanz zu Sandhausen. Wir sehen dann aber den Unterschied zwischen den beiden Teams eben in den kassierten Toren. Das habt ihr ja auch herausgearbeitet. Sandhausen steht da auf einem defensiven Fundament. Nur 14 Gegentreffer in 11 Spielen. Eintracht Braunschweig, 21 Gegentreffer in 11 Spielen. Aber Tim, eine sehr positive Bilanz aus den letzten 5 Spielen. 3 Siege und 2 Unentschieden. Also die sind gerade so richtig in einem Lauf drin. Hat das nur mit Anthony Uccia zu tun oder auch noch mit anderen Faktoren?
Also ich würde vor allem nicht nur Anthony Uccia dazu zählen, der natürlich jetzt auch getroffen hat, die letzten Spiele, aber jetzt gerade Doppelpacker am Wochenende ist Emmanuel Ferrai. Und das ist tatsächlich eine der, ja, für viele eine der Entdeckungen der bisherigen Saison. Ich würde fast sagen, eine nicht geringe Zahl an Leuten, die die 3. Liga in der letzten Saison verfolgt haben und auch den BVB ein bisschen enger verfolgt haben, haben gesagt, wie zur Hölle konnte nur anscheinend Eintracht Braunschweig sich für diesen Spieler interessieren. Er macht jetzt genau das, was er machen soll. Er ist ein wahnsinnig kreativer Fußballer, der allen Zweitligisten gut zu Gesicht stehen würde und hat jetzt gegen St. Pauli tatsächlich nach seiner Einwechslung beide Tore gemacht. Das passt da auch. Das Bemerkenswerte bei Eintracht Braunschweig ist, dass sie in diesen Lauf gekommen sind, wahnsinnig schlecht gestartet sind, wobei sie tatsächlich, was den Fußball anging, gar nicht so schlecht gestartet sind. Sie haben ein Auftragsspiel gegen den HSV gehabt, da haben sie sehr gut gespielt, keine Tore gemacht. HSV hat spät zwei Tore gemacht, hat dann gewonnen. Grundsätzlich finde ich persönlich den Fußball von Eintracht Braunschweig ziemlich ehrlich. Die spielen da in so einem 5-3-2-Defensiv, schalten super schnell um und da ist tatsächlich das ganze Spiel auch darauf ausgerichtet. Uca ist ja an sich zwar schon ein bisschen älter und sehr schneller Spieler. Kaufmann ist daneben oder Lauberbach, die beide auch sehr schnell sind. Dann ist Ferrai, der passt eigentlich fast gar nicht so richtig in das System. Aber er ist einfach ein guter Spieler. Und sonst hat man mit Nicolao, hat man und Berend und Demedina und Benkovic haben sie sich echt gute, stabile, physisch starke Spieler geholt. Und Michael Schiele, der Trainer da, der lässt tatsächlich fast genau den gleichen Stiefel spielen wie in der letzten Saison in der dritten Liga. Mit dieser Art von Fußball sind die auch aufgestiegen. Also ich hatte vorhin über Heidenheim gesprochen, mit der Laufstärke, mit der Anzahl an Sprints. Was intensive Läufe und allgemeine Kilometeranzahl angeht, da ist eigentlich der FC St. Pauli ziemlich nah dran an Heidenheim, beziehungsweise zumindest auf Platz 2. Auf Platz 2, was die Sprints angeht, ist aber Eintracht Braunschweig, weil sie eben so ein schnelles, krasses Umschaltverhalten haben und eben genau darauf auch abzielen. Also das Spiel von denen. Das hat man jetzt auch gegen St. Pauli gesehen. Damit werden sie auch der restlichen Liga noch Probleme bereiten. Also ich persönlich hatte vor der Saison gedacht, für Eintracht Braunschweig wird es ziemlich schnell, ziemlich eng. Aber es zeigt sich irgendwie, dass dieser Fokus auf das Umschaltverhalten und dieser krass defensive Fokus, dass der dieses Jahr wieder en vogue ist in der 2.
FC Nürnberg damals sehr gut funktioniert, dass der Klub in Braunschweig 4-2 verloren hat. Und dann nutze ich dieses Format jetzt mal für ein Bekenntnis, ich bin schuld, also alle Braunschweig-Hasser, ich bin schuld an dieser Erfolgsserie. Ich war nämlich damals mit dem Klub in Braunschweig und ich war im Tageshotel von, es war ein Abendspiel, ich war im Tageshotel von Eintracht Braunschweig untergebracht, die bis dahin noch nichts gewonnen hatten. Wie Tim schon sagt, unglücklich nichts gewonnen hat. Und ich ging durch die Lobby und da saß ganz traurig und alleine Michael Schiele in so einem riesigen Hotel-Sessel. Und dann bin ich an ihm vorbei und dann dachte ich mir, der schaut so traurig aus, dann bin ich zurückgegangen und habe ihm gesagt, viel Glück heute Abend. Und seitdem hat Eintracht Braunschweig einfach nur noch Glück und wird wahrscheinlich am Ende aufsteigen oder sowas. Und also jeder, der Eintracht Braunschweig nicht mag, beschwerde mails an mich.
Und dann alle anderen Trainer einfach mal mit traurigem Blick in die Lobby sitzen und hoffen, dass Fadi vorbei kommt und vielleicht dann auch mich auch Glück wünscht. Ab dann sehe ich schon die Szene, dass das irgendwie durchsickert. Du hast wieder jemandem Glück gewünscht und dann Autokorsos auf den Straßen usw. Aber insofern ja ganz schön, dass du nochmal Michael Schiele ansprichst, weil der hat ja auch eine Vita, wo man das jetzt vielleicht gar nicht unbedingt hätte erwarten können. Also war ja ganz lange bei den Würzburger Kickers Trainer von 2017 bis 2021. Dann 14 Spiele bei Sandhausen. Also ich hatte das schon wieder fast so ein bisschen verdrängt, ehrlicherweise, weil es eben nur 14 Spiele waren. Und jetzt eben in Braunschweig. Und das ist schon interessant. Also mit Ausnahme von Sandhausen, da war sein Punkteschnitt leider gar nicht gut. Bei weniger als einem Punkt pro Spiel. Aber ansonsten ist er jetzt ungefähr so, wie er mit Würzburg damals hat spielen lassen. Da waren es 1, 7 Punkte pro Spiel, jetzt 1, 6. Klar, es ist auch 3. Liga mit dabei. Also bei den Kickers in Würzburg ist es natürlich noch viel mehr. Aber das zeigt, das könnte schon wirklich auch ein Trainertalent sein, was so ein bisschen bisher unter dem Radar gelaufen ist. Bei vielen zumindest, also inklusive mir.
Also ich finde es auf jeden Fall bemerkenswert, wie krass der Fußball ist, den sie spielen. Es gibt ja Teams, die passen sich immer viel an, was ja auch eine taktische Flexibilität vielleicht beinhaltet. Zu Hansa Rooster kommen wir ja noch. Aber der Fußball, den Eintracht Braunschweig spielt, ist schon sehr krass auf dieses Offensivumschaltverhalten ausgelegt. Was mir aufgefallen ist, was ich toll fand, ist, dass Eintracht Braunschweig tatsächlich in der Verteidigung auch sehr mannorientiert mit den Innenverteidigern spielt und genau das Gleiche machen, wie Union Berlin das auch unter Fischer spielen lässt. Da sind nämlich die Innenverteidiger, die ziehen auch mit raus, teilweise auch mit über die Mittellinie, selbst wenn sie tief stehen, wenn die Gegenspieler sich ein bisschen tiefer anbieten wollen. Also da ist eine krasse Mannorientierung drin und das ziehen die einfach durch. Und das ist schon gut, was die spielen. Also es ist schon so, dass, wie gesagt, ich bin der Meinung, dass da noch das eine oder andere Team Probleme haben wird mit Michael Schiele aka der Christian Lindner der 2. Liga. Und jetzt kann man sich mal Fotos von ihm angucken.
Ja, also der arme Mann, lass ihn doch in Ruhe. Jetzt haben wir ihn so viel gelobt und dann musst du ihn doch hinten rauszunehmen.
Ja, ich wollte doch mal einen rein drücken, Mensch.
Ja, also wirklich. Aber ja, interessanter Aspekt, herausrückende Innenverteidiger in einer Fünferkette. Das macht eben Union sehr viel. Freiburg hat das eine ganze Zeit lang gemacht. Da war das immer so ein Teil des Konzepts, auch im Ball besetzt durchaus, dass da mal jemand andribbelt. Ist eben dann leichter, die Lücken zu schließen, wenn du 5 hinten hast, weil natürlich, wenn jemand, der rausrückt, dann ergibt sich in seinem Raum ein, in seinem Rücken ein Raum. Das ist schon ein Element im Fußball. Ehrlicherweise glaube ich, dass wir das relativ bald noch häufiger sehen. Ich finde, Mainz und Fünf macht das auch ähnlich, nicht immer komplett, weil da fangen es manchmal auch die Sechser auf, wenn sich jemand tiefer fallen lässt bei Union. Und eben anscheinend Braunschweig, da habe ich es ehrlich gesagt einfach zu wenig Spiele gesehen, wusste ich bisher nicht. Ist ein festes Element, glaube ich, werden wir noch häufiger sehen. Das sind so Details, die dann vielleicht auch sich in der 2. Liga durchsetzen. Ist die Frage, ob sich bei Jan Regensburg irgendetwas durchgesetzt hat, was wir so vielleicht noch nicht so häufig gesehen haben. Jan Regensburg liegt einen Platz hinter Braunschweig, aber ebenfalls mit 12 Punkten, also es ist eng da unten drin. Regensburg hat es wiederum geschafft, aus 9 Toren 12 Punkte zu erzielen, haben auch 3 Siege, 3 Unentschieden, 5 Niederlagen. Also das ist die Bilanz, die wir jetzt schon ein paar Mal gehört haben, bei Sandhausen, Braunschweig und jetzt eben auch Regensburg. Fadi, was müssen wir da wissen? Also es sah ja im Kalenderjahr gesehen für den Jahren gar nicht gut aus. Und man konnte da schon schlimme Befürchtungen haben, wie es jetzt dann in dieser Saison laufen würde. Jetzt ist die Bilanz durchwachsen, aber gleichzeitig ja auch den Ansprüchen des Jahns vielleicht entsprechend. Wie würdest du es jetzt denn beurteilen nach elf Spieltagen?
Ähnlich darf ich auf Sandhausen, Darmstadt, Heidenheim verweisen. Oder ist ja... Schwierig Fußball zu spielen gegen Jahn Regensburg. Weil sie, glaube ich, auch wieder gerne Zweikämpfe führen und sich auch so ein bisschen durch Überkörperlichkeit definieren. Haben es am Freitag erstaunlicherweise geschafft, gegen die Spielvereinigung Fürth den besseren Fußball zu spielen, als die Fürther, was sehr gegen die ehemals als spielstarke Mannschaft gestatteten Fürther spricht und nur ein bisschen für Jahn Regensburg. So ein bisschen wie Augsburg in der ersten Liga retten sich wahrscheinlich am Ende. Und keiner weiß warum. Oder retten sich deshalb, weil es vorher keinen interessiert. Ich weiß es nicht. Cool, dass sie am Trainer festhalten. Das finde ich immer einigermaßen überzeugend. Was wahrscheinlich auch an so einem Standort wie Regensburg ein bisschen leichter fällt, ist an den vermeintlich großen. Aber Tim wird ein paar Dinge wissen. Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was mich am Jan-Regensburg-Fußball so überzeugen könnte. Und da war ich vorhin auch schon mal, dass ich mir sagte, nächste Woche unbedingt Jan Regensburg gucken. Ist okay, aber es ist halt einfach stinklangweilig. Und ich weiß nicht, ob eine Liga so sein muss.
Also Leute, es ist die beste 2. Liga aller Zeiten, auch aller zukünftigen Zeiten. Ich finde das unmöglich, dass hier so gebäst wird. So darf man gar nicht über die 2. Männer-Bundesliga berichten. Man muss immer sagen, dass es eine richtig tolle Liga ist.
Du erwischst uns in einer schlechten Phase der Saison. Wir müssen das nächste Mal vor dem Saisonstart machen vielleicht. Da ist dann noch mehr Euphorie und Freude.
Bei Jan Regensburg ist es einmal mehr bemerkenswert. Sie sind ja schon ein paar Jahre in der 2. Liga, aber sind tatsächlich auch, was Etat angeht, immer noch einer der kleinen Player in der Liga. Vor der Saison haben wir Jan-Niklas Beste, der war ja Glin von Werder, der ist ja zu Heidenheim gewechselt. Der ist weggegangen. Dann ist Max Bezuschkow, wie ich finde, einer der besten 2. zentralen Mittelfeldspieler der Liga. Der ist nach Hannover gegangen. Das waren schon gerade diese Doppel-Sechs mit Bezuschkow und Gimba. Das war schon eins der Markenzeichen von Jan Regensburg. Diese krasse Physis von Gimba zusammen damit Breitkreuz und Kennedy und Elvedi in der Innenverteidigung. Das ist schon richtig, was Fadi gesagt hat. Diese physische Komponente zieht vielen den Zahn. Andreas Albers vorne führt immer die meisten Kopfballduelle pro Spiel. Wahrscheinlich Liga weit, ganz sicher bin ich mir da jetzt nicht, aber letzte Saison hat er es auf jeden Fall gemacht. Und Regensburg hat ja große Probleme. Die sind ja sehr gut gestartet wieder. Haben sich, glaube ich, in den ersten drei Spielen gar kein Gegentor gefangen. Zwei gewonnen, eins unentschieden. Und dann war dieses 0-0 gegen Nürnberg, war das, glaube ich, Fadi. Haben sie, genau.
Was hast du da dem Trainer schon wieder gesagt, Fadi?
Genau, die haben dann 0-0 gespielt. Und das hat sozusagen das Ganze gedreht. Weil die haben dann, glaube ich, fünf Spiele lang gar nicht mehr getroffen. Also kein einziges Tor erzielt. Die haben dann 0-6 zu Hause gegen den KSC verloren. Und so 4-0 in Düsseldorf. Und hatten echt große Probleme. Aber dann kam das Übliche. Die Aufbaugegner St. Pauli kamen nach Regensburg. Und da haben sie natürlich wieder zweimal getroffen. Haben dann jetzt wieder nicht getroffen. Dann ging Fürth aber auch wieder zweimal getroffen. Und gegen Fürth, das habe ich auch gesehen, das Spiel. Fand ich tatsächlich. Fadi hat gesagt, Fürth war wahnsinnig schlecht. Und zu Fürth kommen wir ja noch. Da möchte ich gar nicht widersprechen. Regensburg hat es aber relativ gut gemacht. Da muss man schon sagen, die Mittel sind ein bisschen limitierter natürlich. Aber ich finde, sie haben durchaus auch richtig entschieden, was da passieren kann. Maximilian Thal ist vor der Saison gekommen. Das ist so ein bisschen der Ersatz für Besuchkov. Der ist aus Paderborn gekommen. Im Paderborn hat er sich nicht so richtig durchsetzen können. Jetzt merkt man aber gerade, es ist ein richtig guter Fußballer. Bei Bundesliga.de gibt es ja diese schönen Statistiken namens Passeffizienz. Da ist er tatsächlich immer doch relativ weit vorne mit dabei. Für Regensburger Verhältnisse ist das sogar richtig weit vorne. Den Umständen, auch den finanziellen Mitteln entsprechend, wird da tatsächlich durchaus wieder was drin sein, dass sie zumindest um den Klassenerhalt mitspielen können. Auch wenn Sarpet Singh ja nicht spielberechtigt ist. Da wurde ja tatsächlich die Genehmigung gar nicht angemeldet zum Spiegelbetrieb, sondern ist ja erst nächstes Jahr wieder spielberechtigt.
Also nicht rechtzeitig angemeldet. Ich glaube, so war es. Man hat es ja nicht vor der Frist hinbekommen. Was schon ein erstaunlicher Vorgang ist und vielleicht auch an anderen Bundesliga-Standorten höhere Wellen geschlagen hätte. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da jetzt Regensburg unrecht tue, aber ich habe da nicht so viel drüber gelesen, wenn das beim HSV passiert wäre, dann hätten wir das überall gehört, bis hin zu Formaten, die sich eigentlich mit der ersten Fußball-Bundesliga der Männer befassen, wie Zeiglas Wunderbare Welt des Fußballs und so.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es da einen Zusammenhang gibt. Ich möchte den auch nicht herstellen, aber ich weiß, dass ein paar Tage vorher der Sportdirektor Roger Stilz aufgehört hat. Der ist aus persönlichen Gründen gekündigt. Kurz ein paar Tage bevor das mit der fehlenden Spielberechtigung oder zu spät eingereichtenen Spielberechtigung publik wurde.
Aber wir wissen nicht, ob es da auch eine Korrelation gibt oder gar eine Kausalität. Das lassen wir da hingestellt. Was wir aber festhalten können, ist, der Jan ist der Jan, eben auch im Jahr 2022 und vermutlich auch 2023 der FC Augsburg der 2. Bundesliga. Ich glaube, das ist das, was so ein bisschen hängen bleibt und vielleicht auch als Kompliment verstanden werden kann. Ganz sicher sogar als Kompliment, glaube ich, wenn man sich die Bilanz des FCA angucken möchte. Jetzt erst kommen wir, lieber Tim, zum FC St. Pauli. Der steht nämlich auf Rang 14 aktuell. Elf Punkte hat man. Man hat damit nur einen Punkt Vorsprung auf die Relikationsplätze. Ich meine, um die direkten Platzierungen geht es jetzt vielleicht nicht eher um die Ergebnisse und die Bilanz. Wenn ich mir allein die letzten sechs Spiele angucke, sehe ich da keinen einzigen Sieg. Ich sehe vier Unentschieden, zwei Niederlagen. Jetzt kommt natürlich ein bisschen ein Spiel, das immer aus der Wertung herausfällt. Denn das Stadtderby ist nochmal etwas ganz Besonderes. Da kann man auch durchaus eine Saison drehen. Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, hat es der FC St. Pauli auch schon mal geschafft, mithilfe dieses Derbys. Aber auch beim FC St. Pauli haben wir es ähnlich wie bei Regensburg. Wenn wir den größeren Rahmen aufmachen, eben das Kalenderjahr zum Beispiel, es läuft nicht mehr so. Und warum ist das der Fall?
Ja, wenn ich das beantworten könnte, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich, dann würde mir eine Ehrennadel vom Verein verliehen werden. Also es ist momentan so. Es gibt mehrere Probleme. Und das muss man wahrscheinlich ganzheitlich betrachten. Es läuft wahrscheinlich alles irgendwie Hand in Hand. Wo fange ich an? Ich suche mir mal eins aus. Zum einen gibt es Probleme, die der FC St. Pauli spielerisch hat, gegen Dreierketten. Das ist eins der Probleme. Jetzt Braunschweig war wieder ein gutes Beispiel. Oder gegen Fünfer Dreierketten. Da haben sie wieder verloren gegen Dreier-Fünfer-Kette. Da ist der Punkteschnitt echt massiv anders. Also St. Pauli holt unter Timo Schulz in der letzten Saison und in dieser Saison, wenn man das zusammenpackt, holt – ich habe jetzt die neueste Statistik, die habe ich mir nicht mehr reingezogen – aber 1, 9 Punkte gegen Teams mit Viererketten und 1, 1 Punkte gegen Teams mit Dreierketten. Also das ist echt ganz extrem. Da wurden – ja, wie soll man sagen – Oke Göttlich hat letzte Woche im Interview mit dem Kicker gehabt, wo er das ganz klar angemahnt hat und gesagt hat, es wurden – im Kalenderjahr wurde es nicht geschafft – gegen gewisse Spielweisen an der Gegner Lösung zu finden. Und das sind eben diese Dreierketten, gegen die es immer Probleme gab. Da hatte der FC St. Pauli zum einen die Probleme, dass sie offensiv nicht mehr ganz so durchsetzungsstark waren, weil die Teams eben sehr defensiv standen. Und zum anderen aber dann zu risikoreich wurde und dann in der Restverteidigung vieles nicht mehr stimmt und sie dann einfach schlicht und ergreifend überlaufen wurden in letzter Reihe. Das ist ein Problem, das ist tatsächlich so ein taktisches Problem, wo der FC St. Pauli dann von der Raute inzwischen auf ein flaches 4-4-2 umgestellt hat. Dafür fehlt aber vielleicht ein bisschen das Personal. Gerade das Tempo auf den Außenbahn, gerade im Mittelfeld. Und das Personal, das leitet dann auch über zum nächsten Punkt. Es ist momentan so, dass der FC St. Pauli offensiv mit den drei Spielern spielt, wenn alle fit sind, die letzte Saison auf der Bank saßen. Also, letzte Saison waren es Maximilian Ditken vielleicht oder Simon Makinok. Vorne im Angriff neben Guido Burgstaller und dahinter Daniel Kofi Tschré. Er hat ja jetzt gesagt, wie er richtig ausgesprochen wird, nicht mehr Jéré. Das hat er jetzt im Startinterview mit Freiburg gesagt. Sein Name wird Tschré ausgesprochen und nicht Jéré. Uns hat er sozusagen alle angelogen damals.
Das haben wir hier schon mal gehört von Sonja Riegel von WN Wiesbaden. Die meinte auch, der hat uns das die ganze Zeit falsch erzählt. Jetzt stehen wir da wie die Deppen.
Aber das waren so die drei Starter. Und dahinter waren eben Dashna, Matanowicz und Amenido. Und die sind jetzt die drei Starter. Und was man sieht, ist tatsächlich, der FC St. Pauli ist was, wenn man sich auf die Expected Goals, darauf möchte ich mich gar nicht zu sehr versteifen, aber wenn man sich die Expected Goals Werte anschaut, dann sieht man eben, dass St. Pauli die zweitbeste Defensive hat und die sechstbeste oder fünfbeste Offensive. Und gerade in der Offensive passt das momentan nicht. Also da geht es tatsächlich um so Kleinigkeiten wie so was wie Torschussgenauigkeit. Der FC St. Pauli kriegt weniger als 30 Prozent seiner Torschüsse, gehen letztendlich auch auf das Tor. Und das ist eine Quote, die ist nur Hansa Rostock hat eine niedrigere Quote. Und das bedeutet beim FC St. Pauli, die ziemlich viel, ziemlich häufig aufs Tor schießen, dass sie fast genauso häufig nur aufs Tor schießen wie der SV Sandhausen, die mit Abstand letzter sind in der Torschussstatistik, also der Anzahl an Schüssen, aber fast genauso viele, nämlich vier Schüsse pro Spiel auf das Tor bekommen. Das ist ein riesengroßes Problem. Gerade diese Torschussgenauigkeit. Da muss man durchaus schon eine Qualitätsfrage stellen beim FC St. Pauli in der Offensive, weil es gelingt ihnen zwar, sich Chancen herauszuspielen, aber es gelingt ihnen aktuell nicht, diese zu verwerten. Da ist die Frage, ob sie momentan einfach ein bisschen Pech haben, ist das eine Phase, die sie überstehen müssen, oder ist es vielleicht eine Qualitätsfrage vorne, dass die Spieler nicht das bringen, was man sich vor der Saison von ihnen erhofft hat. St. Pauli hat lange Zeit noch einen Stürmer gesucht. Die wollten noch diesen Zielspieler, so ein bisschen Ersatz für Guido Burgstaller, haben. Es war schon verwunderlich, dass sie den bisher noch nicht hatten, weil es war wohl schon ziemlich lange klar, dass Guido Burgstaller wieder zurück will nach, naja, Fadi, Nürnberg war ja auch Thema, aber er wollte ja auf jeden Fall näher an die Heimat zurück. Aber das war schon lange Thema, das war auch schon im Frühjahr bekannt, unabhängig davon, wie der St. Pauli die Saison vielleicht beendet, ob sie aufsteigen oder nicht, wenn meine Infos da richtig sind. Und da hätte man sich schon frühzeitig vorbereiten können. Anscheinend sind verschiedene Sachen dann auch nicht geklappt. Christoph Daferner ist dann lieber nach Nürnberg gegangen, bzw. Nürnberg hat dann die Ablöse an Dresden bezahlt. Und ich glaube, im Nachhinein hätte der FC St. Pauli die Ablöse für Daferner wahrscheinlich noch früher gezahlt, wenn man sich anhört, wie sie am Ende der Transferperiode versucht haben, Spieler zu bekommen, für was für Summen und und und. Das ist vielleicht nicht ganz so gut gelaufen in der Transferphase. Und dann fehlt es vorne vielleicht so ein bisschen qualitativ. Vielleicht sind Spieler alle jung, der älteste Angreifer ist 24 Jahre alt. Vielleicht muss sich das einfach nur entwickeln, vielleicht braucht das ein bisschen Zeit. Aber es gibt viele, die sagen schon, das reicht einfach qualitativ nicht. Es gibt andere, die sagen, es ist momentan ein bisschen Pech dabei. Und es gibt noch andere, die sagen, ein bisschen durchatmen, ruhig, das wird schon kommen. Aber das ist so ein Problem in der Offensive, defensiv. Fangen sie sich mehr Gegentore, als sie müssten, nach Expected Goals. Da sind es tatsächlich individuelle Fehler, die immer wieder reinkommen. Jakov Medić ist da ein Spieler, der immer genannt wird, der im Sommer, wo Stuttgart durchaus Interesse hatte, die wollten ihn gerne haben. Aber er ist ein wahnsinnig guter Verteidiger, wahnsinnig guter Innenverteidiger. Aber gerade so Thema Restverteidigung, Entscheidungsfindung, da sind viele Sachen, die eben nicht ganz so gut funktionieren. Und so sind es halt viele Kleinigkeiten. Auch in der letzten, in der Hinrunde oder in der Rückrunde der letzten Saison gab es ja auch durchaus auch überregional, wo davon berichtet, dass es durchaus Knatsch gibt in der Kabine oder zwischen ich sage mal Sportdirektor und Kabine beim FC St. Pauli um auslaufende Verträge wieder kommuniziert wird oder eben genau nicht kommuniziert wird. In Nürnberg, da Andreas Bornemann da ja auch Sportchef war, gab es solche Geschichten ja auch schon mal. Und da mag ich gar keinen Urteil drüber abgeben. Ich glaube, was innerhalb von Fußballer-Kabinen, Profifußball-Kabinen passiert, das können wir uns alle von außen sozusagen gar nicht richtig vorstellen. Aber das gab es halt auch. Und viele haben gesagt, so im Nachhinein auch Spieler. Auch bei uns, bei Mellanton im Interview, James Lawrence zum Beispiel, der jetzt in Nürnberg spielt, der hat gesagt, ja klar, diese Unklarheit mit Verträgen, die hat uns auch ein bisschen behindert im Leistungsvermögen, auch wenn wir das nicht wollten. Das sind so diese drei großen Bereiche, die ich mal zusammenfügen will, ohne jetzt noch fünf Minuten länger Monolog zu halten, was ich problemlos machen könnte.
Ich hätte tatsächlich eine Frage, wie denn die Rolle von Bornemann da im Moment in Hamburg gesehen wird. In diesem Interview ist Göttlicher doch eher auf den Trainer losgegangen, wenn ich das so oberflächlich richtig mitbekommen habe. Aber die Rolle von Bornemann, der ja dann in Nürnberg auch nicht so ganz unumstritten gegangen ist nach seiner Transferphase vor der Erstligasaison, die jetzt auch nicht so wirklich überzeugend gelaufen ist, ist der da vollkommen raus aus der Diskussion im Moment? Oder bist du der Einzige, der ihn mit rein nimmt in die Diskussion?
Wenn man sich anschaut, was Uke Göttlicher im Kicker-Interview gesagt hat, dann anscheinend schon. Das hast du auch ganz richtig gelesen, dass er die sportliche Leitung ein bisschen aus der Haftung genommen hat und er Richtung Trainer gesagt hat, wir finden keine Lösung gegen die Spielweise, oder gegen Spielweisen, nämlich die Dreierketten. Ich persönlich, und das sehen viele beim FC St. Pauli, oder rund um den FC St. Pauli auch so, da gibt es schon Stimmen, die sagen, da lief jetzt im Transfersommer irgendwas nicht so richtig. Man hat das ja mitgekriegt, dass die Kommunikation anscheinend zum Ende der letzten Saison ein Problem gewesen ist beim FC St. Pauli. Grundsätzlich, Andreas Bornemann hat den Kader innerhalb von zwei Jahren einmal komplett umgedreht, komplett auf links gedreht und viele Spieler auch rangeholt, die ja durchaus das erste Mal seit Jahren auch wieder signifikante Transfersum eingespielt haben. Daniel Kofi Tschré hat ja irgendwie – Entschuldigung, jetzt habe ich das extra betont, das wollte ich gar nicht – der hat ja durchaus richtig viel Geld reingespielt, Rekordtransfer, viereinhalb Millionen. Solche Spieler mit der Weitsicht bzw. mit den Ideen, das ist schon bemerkenswert. Andreas Bornemann hat da schon ein Händchen für gehabt. Die letzte Zeit auch Jakov Medec, den er dann rangeholt hat, und und und, Lea Pakarada. Da muss man natürlich auch überlegen, was hat da jetzt besser funktioniert, oder es hat zumindest Hand in Hand gegangen. Also die Spielerentwicklung ist halt auch sehr gut gewesen. Also gerade Kofi hat sich sehr stark und sehr gut entwickelt, gerade was seinen ersten Kontakt angeht, was das Gegenpressing angeht, unter der Leitung von Timo Schulz und seinen beiden Co-Trainer. Also das kommt natürlich auch noch dazu. Und jetzt hat er eben einen Transfersommer gehabt, Andreas Bornemann, wo die Transfers eben nicht sofort funktionieren, wo das nicht sofort eingeschlagen hat. Johannes Ergestein wurde geholt, der hat jetzt drei Tore gemacht, hat jetzt aber auch lange nicht mehr getroffen. Dann wurden Conor Metcalf, Carlo Buccalva wurde geholt. Und eigentlich haben sich jetzt so richtig durchgesetzt, haben sich nur zwei Spieler – nur ist gut, das ist schon ganz ordentlich – das ist Manuel Sayakas auf der rechten Abwehrseite. Da war es aber auch, muss man ehrlich sagen, auch bitter nötig. Und das war tatsächlich so eine der Problemzonen in der letzten Saison, dass die rechte Abwehrseite nicht so richtig gut besetzt war. Die ist jetzt auf jeden Fall besser besetzt. Und David Nimet in der Innenverteidigung ist dazu gekommen. Ein junger Verteidiger, 21. glaube ich, aus Österreich, der bei Mainz vorgespielt hat, oder nicht so viel gespielt hat, ist jetzt gekommen. Auch ein großes Talent, ein sehr großes Talent, ein sehr guter Spieler. Rekordtransfer des FC St. Pauli gewesen. Aber so ganz eingeschlagen, so wie in den Jahren davor, hat das eben nicht. Und da ist jetzt gerade so diese Stürmer-Diskussion, dass da wohl einige Leute der Meinung sind, da fehlen Spieler, da fehlt Qualität. Das wird ihm schon angelastet. Das kann man schon so sagen.
Und wie ernst ist die Lage? Also es ist ja klar, dass man nicht zufrieden sein kann mit dem Saisonverlauf und mit dem Tabellenplatz und auch Teilen der Spielweise, zumindest mit den Ergebnissen, die dann eben bei dieser Spielweise herauskommen. In der überregionalen Presse habe ich schon durchaus gelesen, dass das auch enger werden könnte für Timo Schulz. Ich meine, ihr als Millantoon habt noch mal einen anderen Draht zu ihm. Ihr habt ja dieses bemerkenswerte Podcast-Projekt Being Timo Schulz gemacht. Das möchte ich an der Stelle gerne nochmal empfehlen, werde ich gerne nochmal verlinken. Also ihr habt ihn im Grunde mal enger durch eine Saison hinweg begleitet. Deswegen hast du ja vielleicht auch nochmal einen eigenen Blick auf diese ganze Situation. Also wenn wir uns jetzt von Andreas Bornemann lösen und auf Timo Schulz blicken, was ist da festzustellen?
Also wenn du fragst, wie ernst die Situation ist, dann muss man sagen, die Situation ist auf jeden Fall eine, die man nicht unterschätzen darf. Der FC St. Pauli hat auf jeden Fall einen Kader, bei dem ich sagen würde, qualitativ können die auf jeden Fall mitspielen in den, ich sag mal, Top 8, Top 6 der Liga. Aber die 2. Liga, die Teams in der 2. Liga, das nimmt ja immer mal wieder gerne eine Dynamik an, gerade wenn es auch ergebnistechnisch mal nicht läuft, die dann ja zeitweise auch einfach nicht aufzuhalten ist oder aufzuhalten zu sein scheint. Timo Schulz selber traue ich schon zu, dass er so ein Team da auch rausziehen kann. Das ist ihm ja auch gelungen in seiner ersten Saison. Da sind sie ja auch ähnlich schlecht gestartet, haben dann lange Zeit gar nicht gewonnen. Also fast so eine Serie wie jetzt, auch 1-0 in Braunschweig geführt und dann auch 2-1 verloren. Das ist fast identisch zu dem, was jetzt gerade vorgefallen ist und mithilfe von Transfers im Winter, aber auch mit der Umstellung damals hat Timo Schulz zusammen mit seinem Co-Trainer-Team die Mittelfeldraute installiert. Sie haben es eben da rausgeschafft und dann ein fantastisches Jahr 2021 gespielt. Es ist schwierig einzuschätzen, wer da, wie, wo, welche Verantwortung trägt. Man muss diese Probleme irgendwie ganzheitlich betrachten. Es scheint mir aber so, dass das relativ schwer ist, nicht nur für die Leute von außen, das ganzheitlich zu bewerten, dass das eben Hand in Hand geht. Wenn gewisse Spieler fehlen und dann vielleicht auch ein bisschen die Qualität fehlt, dann ist das natürlich ein Problem. Dann wird taktisch ein bisschen was umgestellt. Das ist auch ein Problem, dass die Dinge nicht ganz so sauber laufen. Dann rumorte das vielleicht ein bisschen in der Kabine. Das heißt, da laufen viele Stränge zusammen. Es gilt viel zu moderieren. Ich traue das Timo Schultz zu, dass er das kann, weil er es schon mal gemacht hat. Aber man muss auch ehrlich sagen, dadurch, dass man das jetzt wieder in so eine Art tief reinkommt und momentan die Ergebnisse nicht stimmen, ich würde fast sagen, die Ergebnisse stimmen noch nicht, weil sie halt viele Spieler auch besser waren. Auch tatsächlich, wenn man sich so die Statistiken anschaut, auch besser gewesen sind. Dann nimmt das halt so eine Dynamik ein und die gilt es aufzuhalten. Das kann man als Trainer, muss man das eigentlich schaffen. Ansonsten wird es schnell eng. St. Pauli ist zwar in vielen Sachen, freue ich mich immer drüber, wenn es dann doch ein bisschen anders läuft als bei anderen Fußballklubs, aber davon kann man sich natürlich nicht unendlich frei machen. Also irgendwann wird das auch eng für jemanden wie Timo Schulz.
Ich sehe da so ein bisschen Parallelen in der Art und Weise, wie der Trainer verankert ist im Verein und wie er eigentlich so generell gesehen wird zu Pellegrino Matarazzo beim VfB Stuttgart, wo man sich jetzt von ihm getrennt hat, aber unter großen Schmerzen. Man hat diesen Schmerz selbst auch gespürt, dass man das Gefühl hatte, es gibt jetzt gar keine andere Möglichkeit mehr, als einen Trainer gehen zu lassen, den man eigentlich gut findet und der eigentlich auch gut zum Verein passt. Ich möchte jetzt nicht deswegen sagen, dass Timo Schulz entlassen wird. Dafür bin ich viel zu weit weg und habe da logischerweise auch zum Glück nichts mitzureden. Aber so ein bisschen Parallelen erkenne ich dazu. Es scheint ja jemand zu sein, der eigentlich sehr, sehr, sehr gut zu St. Pauli passt und wo sich eigentlich alle Beteiligten wünschen würden. Bitte, bitte, lasst es noch ganz. Bitte werde unser Frank Schmidt. Aber so funktioniert eben Fußball manchmal auch nicht.
Nee, genau. Also das hofft man natürlich, dass irgendwie das Timo Schulz der Christian Streich oder Frank Schmidt wird und dass das lange Jahre irgendwie gut geht. Aber ja, also letztendlich ist es total billig, aber zählt halt das Ergebnis irgendwie. Und da hoffe ich manchmal, dass das jetzt gerade in der aktuellen Phase vielleicht ein bisschen weniger auf die Ergebnisse, sondern mehr auf den Fußball, den St. Pauli spielt, geschaut wird und dann eben vielleicht auch erkannt wird, dass die Abschlussschwäche momentan eins der zentralen, wenn nicht sogar das zentralste Problem ist des FC St. Pauli zusammen mit so individuellen Fehlern in der Defensive. Und dass es vielleicht taktisch gar nicht unbedingt so das größte Problem ist, sondern tatsächlich eher so entweder eine Pechsträhne, eine sehr ausgedehnte, lange Pechsträhne, die sie haben, oder eben auch eine Frage der Qualität. Und vielleicht muss auch einfach nur, braucht man ein bisschen Zeit, bis Spieler sich entwickeln. Also schwierig und du hast vollkommen recht, man viele, eigentlich alle beim FC St. Pauli, wünschen sich, dass diese Liaison zwischen Schultz und dem FC St. Pauli, dass die noch lange anhält.
Wir werden es beobachten und haben leider jetzt aber auch die perfekte Überleitung zum 1. FC Nürnberg. Also Magdeburg überspringen wir. Die Ligen auf Rang 15 mit 10 Punkten und Punkt gleich. Mit ihnen liegt eben der Klub. Und warum sage ich leider? Ja, weil hier hat es den Trainerwechsel schon gegeben. Robert Klauß ist nicht mehr Trainer beim Klub. Dafür ist ein altes, bekanntes Gesicht zurückgekehrt. Markus Weinziel, aber der erwünschte Trainer-Effekt, er war vielleicht nur in Phasen zu sehen oder vielleicht auch gar nicht. Fadi, wie würdest du denn jetzt den Start bewerten?
Ja, in Phasen war es dieses Spiel am Wochenende so ein typisches Nach-Trainer-Wechselspiel. Alle engagiert, viele Abschlüsse aus den absurdesten Positionen. Also sehr viel Aktionismus, aber schon auch ein bisschen besseres Spiel, als man das in den letzten Wochen vom 1. FC Nürnberg gesehen hat. Wobei man da immer das vorletzte Heimspiel gegen Aminia Bielefeld ein bisschen ausklammern muss, weil das auch gut war, auch wenn es erst spät gewonnen wurde. Aber ja, ich glaube, so stellt man sich ein Spiel nach dem Trainerwechsel vor. Alle können plötzlich ein bisschen mehr rennen und ein bisschen besser passen. Und was man sich dann nicht vorstellt, ist dieser Einbruch in den letzten 40 Minuten, der dann dem Klub passiert ist. Aber ich finde das tatsächlich ganz interessant, diese Diskussion auch auf St. Pauli, weil wir die in Nürnberg jetzt auch schon eine Zeit lang führen. Flo Zenger, euch beiden und vielleicht auch einigen Menschen da draußen ganz gut bekannt, hat in unserem Podcast mich mit erstaunlicher Verspätung mal aufmerksam gemacht auf diesen einen Text, dieses, glaube ich, englische Sportjournalisten, stop blaming the manager, it's the sporting director's fault. Seitdem bin ich tatsächlich in einer gedanklichen Zwickmühle, weil ich mir denke, ja, auch in Nürnberg ist die Transferphase im Sommer vielleicht nicht so geil gewesen, wie man sich gewünscht hat, also auch da eine Parallele zu St. Pauli. Und ob man dann nicht mal so eine Saison einfach durchhält, weil man sagt, okay, wir haben scheiße investiert, vielleicht die zwei, drei Schlüsselpositionen nicht so gesetzt, wie es eigentlich hätte sein sollen. Und dann versuchen wir mal durch diese Saison mit dem Trainer zu kommen. Es ist keine Mehrheitsmeinung offenbar, zumindest beim 1. FC Nürnberg, weil da hat man sich dann halt für Markus Weinziel entschieden. Das heißt noch niemals, dass ich jetzt sonderlich überzeugt war von der Arbeit von Robert Klaus, der jetzt nicht immer besonders attraktiven Fußball hat spielen lassen in Nürnberg aus ästhetischer Sicht, der es aber geschafft hat, den Klub damals nach diesem Fast-Absturz in die 3. Liga auf seiner ersten Profi-Cheftrainerstation doch zu stabilisieren mit Klassenverbleib im ersten Jahr und dann so ein bisschen Aufstiegsrennen im zweiten Jahr und so was. Ein bisschen langweilig fand ich das dann, den jetzt schon rauszuschmeißen und dann so einen Trainer zu holen, der – kann man ihn den Sandhausen der Trainerbranche nennen? Oder das Augsburg? Augsburg passt bei ihm wahrscheinlich besser, aber wo man sich jetzt auch nicht denkt, ja, geil, Markus Weinziel-Spiele muss man mal gesehen haben, wenn man sich wirklich für Fußball interessiert. Oder muss man? Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht. Seid ihr Markus Weinziel-Fans?
Naja, Augsburg unter Markus Weinziel war immer so ganz gut der Durchschnitt der ersten Liga. Und wenn man quasi wissen wollte, wo stehe ich in der Liga? Wenn du gegen sie gewinnst, dann stehst du irgendwie besser als Platz 10. Wenn du gegen sie verlierst, dann stehst du drunter. Dafür hat es sich gelohnt. Lass mal noch kurz bei Robert Klauß bleiben, weil das finde ich jetzt gerade fast noch interessanter als Markus Weinziel. Dem muss man jetzt ja auch erstmal ein paar Spiele Zeit geben, um zu sehen, wie er überhaupt spielen lässt. Und vielleicht passt ja auch der Fußball, den Markus Weinziel spielen lässt, ganz gut in diese 2. Liga. Also ein paar Dinge, die du vorhin in deinem Rund erwähnt hast, da dachte ich mir, na mal gucken, ob so der Klub nicht auch spielen wird. Aber erstmal zu Robert Klauß. Wie würdest du denn jetzt dann seine Zeit beim Klub abbinden? Er war ja relativ häufig umstritten. Ich glaube, es hatte auch so ein bisschen mit seiner Art zu kommunizieren zu tun. Und da will ich jetzt nicht nur auf diesen einen – ja, weiß nicht, war ja nicht mein, eh klar – aber wo er einmal eine Reporterfrage sehr, sehr im Trainersprech beantwortet hat und das dann viele Leute amüsiert und so weiter hat. Aber das ist ja generell war das jetzt insofern typisch für ihn, dass er eben jemand war, der durchaus zu dieser jungen Trainergilde gehört, die ihm einfach viel in ihren Fachbegriffen sprechen, die auch durchaus bereit sind, Dinge dann zu erklären, die damit aber auch, ich würde sagen, Abwehrmechanismen im Fußball-Establishment und vielleicht auch auf Seiten der Journalistinnen und Journalistinnen manchmal wecken können. Und wenn dann die Ergebnisse nicht stimmen, hat man das Gefühl, dass da manchmal zumindest – also das ist jetzt nur eine subjektive Meinung meinerseits – aber ich hatte das Gefühl, manchmal hat da so eine gewisse Helme auch mitgeschwungen dann in der Berichterstattung. Na schau, so schlau ist der Herr Lepto-Trainer dann ja auch nicht. Würdest du dem zustimmen?
Ja, unbedingt. Das war sicherlich so. Also gerade nach dieser Pressekonferenz, glaube ich nach dem Spiel gegen St. Pauli, als er nach dem Matchplan gefragt wurde, den der Kollege damals nicht erkannt hatte, da ist ja wirklich viel von diesem alten weißen Männerhass auf ihn eingepasselt, obwohl es, wenn man sich die Antworten mal mit etwas Verstand angehört hat, war es ja wirklich sehr einfach verständlich und die Hürde zum Verständnis hin nicht besonders hoch. Er hatte, glaube ich, nicht so wirklich Bock auf Medienarbeit. Ich weiß nicht, ob das alte, gute Red Bull-Schule ist. Er hat aber, ich finde, in diesen zwei, ein Viertel, zweieinhalb Jahren sich in der Hinsicht durchaus gesteigert und vor allem hat er praktisch nie bis sehr selten Bullshit erzählt. Man konnte Robert Klaus tatsächlich Dinge fragen und er hat die Frage beantwortet und musste sich nicht in 700 Floskeln oder Phrasen flüchten und das fand ich immer sehr angenehm. Wenn es eine Scheißfrage war, dann hat er die auch so beantwortet, aber trotzdem nicht in diesen wirklich langweiligen Trainer-Phrasen Deutsch, dass der Einsatz stimmen muss und Kratzen beißen und so was. Es waren immer sehr interessante Antworten. Er hat vor der ersten Pokalrunde den 1. FC Kahn Marienborn, die – ich kann mich schon gar nicht mehr erinnern, ich glaube jetzt Regionalliga oder Oberliga spielen – auf jeden Fall hat er die auch in der Pressekonferenz so seziert, taktisch wie er es sonst halt bei der normalen Zweitligakonkurrenz macht. Also da war auch viel Ernsthaftigkeit und Respekt dem jeweiligen Gegner gegenüber immer zu verspüren. Also ich persönlich fand die Arbeit mit ihm zunehmend angenehmer hier in Nürnberg. Gegen nicht allen Kollegen so kann ich in vielen Fällen verstehen, weil wie gesagt, manchmal konnte man seine Art durchaus als etwas schnippisch interpretieren. War sie aber in meinen Augen nicht. Also ich fand es immer angenehmer. Aber das war schon sowas, was dann bei vielen im Umfeld auch den Reflex, haha, jetzt mal weg mit dem. Und der Bubi-Laptop-Trainer und sowas.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall so, da muss ich dir voll zustimmen. Diese Pressekonferenzen mit Robert Klauß, die sind echt richtig erfrischend gewesen. Das fand ich nämlich auch immer, wenn St. Pauli gegen Nürnberg gespielt hat, da habe ich das natürlich auch vor und nach den Spielen verfolgt. Und da war es echt auffällig, dass man wenig diese typischen Phrasen gehört hat und viel wirklich spielspezifische Antworten, wo man doch auch schon so eine Liebe zum Detail bei ihm auch gemerkt hat, dass er da sich wirklich intensiv mit was befasst und sich auch – also, ja, so eine gegenseitige – also wirklich so ein Zeichen des Respekts, dass man da – dass er die Frage im Grunde so zurückgespiegelt hat, wie sie kam. Also wenn es eine blöde Frage war, dann hat er sie auch – na ja, da hat er sie mehr oder minder abhundariert. Aber wenn er das Gefühl hatte sozusagen, da hat jemand sich Gedanken gemacht und will auch was hinaus, dann ist er darauf auch eingegangen und hat sich – also hat wirklich, wie du sagst, ehrlich die Frage beantwortet und auch vielleicht gerade heraus auch immer häufig das gesagt, was er denkt und das ist ihm ja auch das eine oder andere mal so ein bisschen auf die Füße gefallen.
Ja, und es ist also tatsächlich, es muss ein Trainer jetzt vielleicht nicht der rhetorische Überflieger sein, aber wenn man sich dann diese Antrittspressekonferenz mit Markus Weinzierl anhört, da hatte man so das Gefühl, der ballert in 20 Minuten jetzt all die Phrasen raus, die sich Robert Klaus 2, 5 Jahre vom Mund abgespart hat irgendwie. Und wie gesagt, es langt noch nicht um eine Meinung, sich zu bilden über Markus Weinzierl, aber der Unterschied war deutlich in der öffentlichen Darstellung seiner selbst.
Aber woran ist Nürnberg denn gescheitert eigentlich? Also woran ist Klaus dann gescheitert? Also ich meine, letzte Saison war das offensiv auch immer noch kein Spektakel, aber ich hatte eigentlich gedacht, die haben das Mittelfeld ja doch zusammengehalten, ja gut, bis auf Tom Kraus, aber die haben ja eigentlich mit Dua und Daferna zwei Stürmer geholt, von denen man gesagt hat, das sind die Puzzleteile, die fehlen bei Nürnberg.
Ja, beide sehr begeistert aufgenommen wurden hier in Nürnberg, Dua und Daferna, jetzt sind die Zweifel ein bisschen größer geworden, weil sie nicht so wirklich ins Spiel eingebunden werden. Ich glaube, das war das große Problem, dass es so die offensive Idee Robert Klauß nie hat entwickeln können. In den besten Momenten hier in Nürnberg war das auch immer eine Mannschaft von Robert Klauß, die dann auch mit Wucht und sich selbst begeistern irgendwie ins Spiel gefunden hat. Und ein ganz großer Fehler, auf den vor der Saison ein paar Menschen hier in Nürnberg hingewiesen haben, der aber von den meisten ignoriert wurden, weil alle, unter anderem auch ich, auf Dua und Daferna mit glänzenden Augen geblickt haben, ist einfach, dass im defensiven Mittelfeld einer fehlt, der so ein Spiel ein bisschen ordnen kann. Im Verein dachten sie, das macht Johannes Geiss, der aber zu oft inzwischen beweist, dass er ein bisschen zu langsam ist für diesen Fußball in der zweiten Liga. Und dann gibt es da einfach keinen. Also jetzt versuchen sie es dann immer mal wieder mit einer Doppel-Sex, mit wechselndem Personal, das irgendwie aufzufangen. Es ist immer fachfremdes Personal. Lino Tempelmann ist einmal Fabian Nürnberger, beide eher 8er, der einzige, der wirklich noch ein defensiver Mittelfeldspieler oder ein 6er ist, ist Sadik Fofana, eine Leihgabe, aber eben auch erst 19 Jahre jung. Der muss jetzt sehr viel Verantwortung übernehmen, macht das defensiv gut, aber ist im Spiel nach vorne auch keiner, der sich da jetzt sonderlich viel zutraut, was logisch ist. Und das ist so, glaube ich, das größte Problem, das in den Momenten in Nürnberg um die Ohren fliegt, dass da einer fehlt auf der Position. Dann gibt es noch so ein paar andere Baustellen, wie die Außenverteidiger einerseits bedingt durch den Ausfall von Tim Handwerker mit seinem Kreuzbandriss und so. Das haben Dieter Hecking und Olaf Rebbe, die sich ja zu zweit um die Kaderplanung kümmern, bisher immer so ein bisschen abgetan als Schmaden. Und jetzt neuerdings hört man auch von den beiden, dass sie jetzt im Winter mal gucken wollen, ob sich da nicht doch noch irgendwo einer findet, der die Position spielen kann.
Ja, lass doch gerne mal über die beiden sprechen, denn jetzt haben wir über die Trainerfrage schon kurz gesprochen. Ich glaube, wie gesagt, Weinzell ist jetzt zu kurz da, um da jetzt Annahmen zu treffen, die über Vermutungen hinausgehen. Aber gerade die Rolle von Dieter Hecking und auch Olaf Rebbe, die ist ja interessant, auch in dieser Doppelkonstellation. Und ich habe auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl in der Stellung von Dieter Hecking vor allem. Also der hat sein Wort, hat ein großes Gewicht. Man war auch meiner Auffassung nach sehr stolz, dass er zum Club gekommen ist. Und gleichzeitig hat er sich ja aber sehr lange auch vor Robert Kraus gestellt. Und damit ja auch so ein bisschen jetzt nicht sein Schicksal mit seinem verknüpft. Das ist immer so eine Floske, die mir sagt, das ist jetzt zu viel in diesem Fall. Aber dennoch merkt man jetzt auch hier in der Diskussion, wir sprechen jetzt nicht mehr nur über den Trainer, wir sprechen auch über so Fragen der Kaderzusammenstellung und eben Fehler oder vielleicht auch Fehleinschätzungen, die da passiert sind. Welche Stellung hat er gerade im Verein?
Im Verein glaube ich eine relativ gute. Sein Vertrag soll jetzt sehr zeitnah noch verlängert werden. Nur rund um den Verein wächst die Skepsis natürlich. Die gab es zu Beginn seiner Amtszeit hier eher nicht. Da waren wirklich alle sehr froh, dass Dieter Hecking nach Nürnberg, der große Dieter Hecking, zum tief gefallenen 1. FC Nürnberg zurückkommt und sich dessen annimmt. Was Hecking damals geschafft hat, muss man im Hoch anrechnen, ist tatsächlich den Verein so ein bisschen zu beruhigen. Weil es war damals mit diesen Relegationsspielen doch alles sehr aufgelegt und mit seinem Vorgänger Robert Palikucar. Also es war sehr viel durcheinander und da muss man sagen, Dieter Hecking hat es sehr gut hinbekommen. Ich fand auch die Einstellung von Robert Klauß überraschend mutig damals, womit ich so meine Probleme oder wo ich meine Bedenken hatte, ob Dieter Hecking, der zweifelsohne ein sehr guter Fußballtrainer war oder ist, ob der auch das strategische Denken mitbringt, dass es vielleicht für einen Sportvorstand braucht. Die Zweifel habe ich immer noch. Die Zweifel gab es offenbar auch im Verein, weil man Dieter Hecking gesagt hat, er darf sich gerne noch jemanden zur Seite holen. Dass er das dann mit Olaf Rebbe getan hat, hat im Verein dann doch einige überrascht, weil Olaf Rebbe ja eher das Feld abdeckt, von dem er dachte, in dem kennt sich auch Dieter Hecking gut aus, nämlich in dieser Spielersuche und Kaderplanung. Man dachte, er holt sich einen zur Seite, der mehr so für das strategische Entwickeln des Vereins zuständig ist. Ja, also eine etwas komische Konstellation. Ich hätte mir jetzt von Dieter Hecking gewünscht, dass er ein bisschen länger das mit diesem Trainer durchhält, zumal er erst im Sommer den Vertrag mit Robert Klauß verlängert hat. Meine Skepsis ist nicht weniger geworden, eher ein bisschen gewachsen, ob das so eine coole Besetzung dieser Position Sportvorstand ist. Aber noch bin ich damit in Nürnberg eine Minderheit.
Ja, ich meine, was ich interessant finde, ist – das wäre jetzt auch das Letzte, was ich dich noch fragen würde, sonst wird das hier zu lange – aber wenn wir jetzt mal die Häme abziehen, und die vielleicht auch Markus Weins hier nicht verdient hat, denn meine Güte, der ist ein erfolgreicher Trainer, erfolgreicher als ganz viele andere Trainer, und nur weil der breiten Masse der Fußball oder vielleicht auch die Vereine nicht gefällt, bei denen er mal trainiert hat. Ja, das ist halt dann so. Aber da, finde ich, muss man dann auch so ein bisschen was abziehen. Aber was man ja schon festhalten kann, glaube ich, ist, dass es einen deutlichen Wechsel in der Spielidee zu geben scheint. Und das ist dann ja letztlich auch so ein strategisches Thema, wie du es gerade angesprochen hast. Kannst du dir denn erklären, wie Markus Weinzel zu dem passen soll, wie bisher der Kader gebaut wurde? Und ist vielleicht dieser Wechsel in der Spielidee gar nicht so krass, wie er für mich aussieht? Weil ich eben das Gefühl hatte, dass Robert Klauß jemand war, der eigentlich auch viel über Pressing und Intensität und Umschaltfußball und vertikalem Fußball spielen lassen will. Und Markus Weinziel ist jemand, der zumindest in seinen letzten Stationen und vor allem jetzt zuletzt auch beim FC Augsburg zwar auch Umschaltfußball spielen lassen will, aber tief aus der eigenen Hälfte heraus. Also das ist kein Angriffspressing, was da gespielt wird. Und dementsprechend brauchst du ja auch extrem schnelle Spieler, Spieler, die es auch schaffen, aus diesen Situationen heraus dann präzise lange Bälle zu spielen. Du brauchst vielleicht einen Zielspieler vorne drin, der auch mal eine Ablage machen kann, einen Ball festmachen kann, bis alle anderen nachgerückt sind. Passt das denn zu dem, was er da vorfindet beim Klub?
So wie du es gerade sagst, nein.
Hoffentlich irre ich mich.
So wie es am Wochenende ausgesehen hat, kann es funktionieren, natürlich. Das ist schwierig. Die Spielidee beim 1. FC Nürnberg war ja gerade eben nicht mehr so wirklich zu erkennen. Vielleicht ist es da vollkommen egal, mit welcher Spielidee einer nach Nürnberg kommt und versucht, etwas Neues anzufangen. Schnell ist die Mannschaft, bis auf Quattrodur wirklich nicht. Lino Tempelmann vielleicht noch mit Abstrichen. Kann ich schwierig einschätzen. Das ist so eine Tim-Frage. Die muss der jetzt aus dem Off nochmal beantworten. Aber ich bin auch da skeptisch. Aber lass mich gerne überraschen. Ich bin da nicht so vorurteilsfrei wie du, was Markus Weinziel betrifft. Du bist da Vornehmer.
Also grundsätzlich würde ich ja sagen, was Markus Weinziel betrifft, ich habe jetzt auch nicht gedacht, wow, da hat der FCN jetzt einen Trainer geholt, der richtig für einen speziellen Fußball steht. Aber genau das ist ja vielleicht auch bei vielen Trainern auch gar nicht so der Fall, weil was man ja auch immer vergisst, ist, dass viele Trainer ja auch durchaus nicht unbedingt nur für einen Fußball stehen. Also es sind ja nicht alle Tim Walters sozusagen, die immer so einen ganz radikalen Fußball denken, sondern die meisten Trainer versuchen ja einfach, das Beste aus einem Kader zu machen. Und wenn Markus Weinzier eben gar nicht die Möglichkeit hat, aus dem Kader ein ballbesitzorientiertes, offensiv kreatives Team zu machen, dann ist das eben so. Und irgendwann kommt man natürlich als Trainer auch in so eine Schublade. Stichwort Michael Schiele, der eben diesen krassen Umschaltfußball spielen lässt. Und dann wird man sagen, ja, für den Fußball braucht man jemanden wie Michael Schiele. Dass so ein Trainer vielleicht noch ganz andere Möglichkeiten hätte, auch in seinem Kopf drin, das wird ja bei vielen häufig gar nicht so weiter gedacht. Also ich finde, so ein Trainerwechsel allgemein, finde ich, mitten in der Saison, Trainerwechsel, ist immer ein Zeichen dafür, dass die Fehlerkultur in einem Verein vielleicht gar nicht so gut funktioniert. Es sei denn, es ist ein Trainer, der sich massiv vergriffen hat im Ton oder massive Fehler gemacht hat oder auf einmal bocklos zum Training kommt oder so. Aber gerade weil du auch gesagt hast, dass da im Sommer der Vertrag verlängert wurde, sowas finde ich dann ganz schwierig. Und da ist immer ganz schwierig gerade diese Verbindung, und die finde ich auch ähnlich zum FC St. Pauli tatsächlich, die Verbindung mit ja, okay, bei der Transferpolitik ist vielleicht auch nicht so viel richtig gelaufen. Und dann da natürlich der Trainer ist dann das einfachere und natürlich auch das günstigere Opfer, aber es ist dann letztendlich ja auch immer noch purer Aktionismus, weil man von etwas, von dem man Monate vorher noch überzeugt war, nämlich das reicht für eine Vertragsverlängerung, ist man auf einmal nicht mehr überzeugt, und gibt dafür ja durchaus signifikante Summen an Geld aus, um jemand anderen ran zu holen, das finde ich immer schwierig. So da, so dieses, ja, das so anzugehen. Und wenn man davon so überzeugt ist, dass man einen Vertrag mit einem Trainer verlängert im Sommer, dann ja, sagst du es vielleicht ganz richtig, aber vielleicht hat man diesen Komfort, diese Zeit nicht, einfach zu sagen, okay, hier sind mehrere Sachen auch in der Transferpolitik vielleicht falsch gelaufen, wir müssen das jetzt gemeinsam durchziehen und nehmen dann nächste Saison nochmal Anlauf. Dafür muss man aber auch die Gewissheit haben, okay, wir steigen dieses Jahr nicht ab, wir können uns das leisten, das durchzuziehen. Und das wäre dann sozusagen die Bereitschaft, die man vielleicht auch mal mitbringen muss als Team und die auch tatsächlich auch alle wünschen sich, dass man Heidenheim oder Freiburg ist, was die Trainerposition angeht. Ich meine, Freiburg, was haben die mit Christian Streich durchgemacht, also das muss man sich dann ja auch mal anschauen. Heidenheim ist auch fast abgestiegen mit Frank Schmidt in einem Jahr und die haben trotzdem da festgehalten und sind da trotzdem irgendwie durchgegangen. Und ja, ich glaube, häufig ist diese Fehlerkultur im Fußballverein ein großes Problem und Trainer raus Schmiss immer ein Zeichen dafür, dass es nicht nur auf der Trainerposition Probleme gibt.
Zumal, wenn du die Arbeit von diesem Trainer seit zwei Jahren kennst und du weißt, er war schon mal in der Krise, ist er meist wieder einigermaßen rausgekommen. Also ich kann es verstehen, wenn so etwas wie in Bielefeld du einen neuen Trainer holst und nach vier Spieltagen merkst, funktioniert gar nicht, dann finde ich einen Trainerwechsel okay im laufenden Betrieb. Aber so immer kompliziert wirkt es immer so ein bisschen, als würde man sich vor allem selbst aus der Schusslinie nehmen. Und das ist halt wirklich so dieser alte Fußball, jetzt kommt mal neuer Impuls und alle wieder kratzen, beißen. Und da weiß ich nicht, ob das nicht inzwischen ein bisschen überholt ist. Zumal es jetzt wirklich sind 11 Spieltage rum, also es ist noch nicht so weit. Du hast bald die WM-Pause und sowas, kannst dir da nochmal überlegen, ob du vielleicht nochmal komplett was anders machen willst. Aber das hat immer so den Hauch von Panikmodus, finde ich.
Zumal ja die Abstände noch gering sind. Also zwischen Platz 10 und Platz 16, über den wir jetzt gerade sprechen, liegen drei Punkte. Und zwischen Platz 10 und Platz 18 liegen nur fünf Punkte. Also sprich, da ist alles noch so, wie es ja auch häufig ist in diesem Stadium der Saison, noch sehr eng beieinander. Das betrifft jetzt auch die letzten beiden Teams, über die wir noch kurz sprechen wollen. Wir bleiben noch ein bisschen bei dir, Fadi, in deinem Einzugsbereich. Du hast es ja schon vorher gesprochen, dass du gerade im Zentrum der guten Laune der Liga bist, weil du eingeklemmt bist zwischen dem 1. FC Nürnberg auf Platz 16 und der Spielvereinigung Kräuterfurt auf Platz 17. Und da haben wir ja genau diesen Fall. Wir haben einen neuen Trainer, Mark Schneider, mit dem man einige Hoffnungen verbunden hat. Wir haben vor allem jemanden, der gegangen ist, mit Leitel zu Hannover 96. Die Hörerinnen und Hörer haben es mitbekommen. Wie würdest du denn jetzt dann so ein Zwischenfazit ziehen? Fürth ist die einzige Mannschaft, die nur einmal gewinnen konnte in elf Spielen, aber immerhin sechs unentschieden. Also dadurch ja neun Punkte geholt.
Ja, da stehe ich jetzt leider ein bisschen unter dem Einfluss, meines Kollegen Michael Fischer, der einen sehr einsamen Kampf für einen Trainerwechsel in Fürth führt, bislang aus seiner Sicht noch erfolglos. Schwierig. Die Spielmeinung Fürth ist ja einigermaßen furios in die Saison gestartet, zwar nur 2 zu 2 gegen Holstein Kiel im ersten Heimspiel, aber mit einem Torschussverhältnis von irgendwie so 1 Milliarde zu 2. Dieses Spiel nicht gewonnen und es gab dann so einen kleinen Knacks, glaube ich, danach, dass der Derby verloren in Nürnberg, was den Fürthern alle 30 Jahre mal passiert, dass sie das nicht gewinnen. Dann hat sich so ein bisschen die Stimmung gewandelt, Pokal aus noch bei den Stuttgarter Kickers nach einem wirklich schlechten Spiel. Und jetzt ist von diesem Fürther-Flachpass, den sie in Fürth so gerne feiern, da bilden sie sich ja zu Recht immer einiges auf die Spielstärke ihrer Mannschaften an. Jetzt ist einfach nicht mehr viel davon da. Beim Sieg zuletzt gegen Paderborn, beim ersten Saisonsieg, gab es dann einen sehr destruktiven Ansatz, der dann auch noch Erfolg hatte, was dazu führt, dass er beibehalten wird. Und ja, große Unzufriedenheit in Fürth. Rashid Azusi, der Sportdirektor, hält aber mit erstaunlicher Coolness noch an Marc Schneider fest.
Was ja, wenn wir so ein bisschen das, was wir gerade gesprochen haben, transferieren, auch nicht so schlimm sein muss.
Was nicht so schlimm sein muss, was aber wieder dem widerspricht, wenn ein Trainer neu in eine Stadt oder zu einem Verein kommt und man sieht, es funktioniert nicht, dann darf man, finde ich, nach dem Keblawi-Gesetz, dann darf man. In Fürth weigern sie sich noch, sagen, fünf Punkte aus den letzten drei Spielen ist okay, geht aufwärts. Ja, es ist spannend, aber wie gesagt, es trägt nicht zur guten Laune hier in der Region bei, dass die Spielvereinigung, also bei den Clubfans wahrscheinlich freuen sich die meisten doch, dass die Spielvereinigung noch hinter dem Club steht, aber ja, so. Für das Arbeiten in der Sportredaktion ist es gerade ein bisschen schwierig. Ich bin gespannt, es ist erstaunlich, dass Marc Schneider, obwohl er wirklich viel Kritik auch von uns abbekommt, immer noch ein sehr freundlicher, netter Gesprächspartner ist. Ich habe den Michael Fischer jetzt zwei- dreimal vertreten. Und wirklich ein sehr netter Mensch, Marc Schneider, aber halt im Moment noch kein erfolgreicher vierter Fußballtrainer.
Das geht leider nicht immer Hand in Hand, aber vielleicht kann das noch so werden. Du hast es ja auch gerade schon angesprochen, diese Unentschieden, also diese Punkte, die man jetzt doch zuletzt gesammelt hat. Also es gab ein 2 zu 1 gegen Paderborn, es gab ein 1 zu 1 gegen Sandhausen, jetzt ein 2 zu 2 gegen den Jan und ja auch ein 2 zu 2 Tim gegen St. Pauli, wo man vielleicht so eins der Probleme von Furt sehen konnte, nämlich egal eigentlich wie Spiele laufen, man kann sich nie sicher sein, ob Furt nicht irgendwie die Punkte noch wegschmeißt oder zumindest die Mehrfachpunkte wegschmeißt. Wie hast denn du da die Spielvereinigung erlebt?
Also auf jeden Fall als einen fast schon klassischen Absteiger, das kann man wahrscheinlich schon so sagen, also nicht Absteiger aus der 2. Liga, sondern ein Team, das oben runterkommt in die neue Liga.
Ich bin auch so erschrocken. Erzählt mir nämlich Michael Fischer die ganze Zeit, dass er als Absteiger aus der 2. Liga sieht. Also gut.
Ja, nein, so weit gehe ich noch nicht, aber es ist tatsächlich schon so, man muss einfach sagen, dass Bielefeld, zu denen kommen wir ja gleich noch, und die haben einfach diese typischen Anpassungsprobleme, die Teams nun mal haben, wenn sie aus der 1. Liga abgestiegen sind und dann eben sich in gewisser Art und Weise personell neu aufstellen müssen. Auf der Trainerbank haben sich beide ja auch neu aufgestellt und dann aber auch an den Fußball erst mal gewöhnen müssen, der da gespielt wird. Und dann eben gute Beispiele sind Regensburg, Sankt Hausen. Da kommen dann auf einmal Teams, die echt so gar keinen Bock haben auf eigene Spielkultur, Spielkontrolle. Und das ist in der 1. Liga, auch wenn es da auch viele Teams gibt, die den Ball gerne weggeben, ja doch noch schon mal ein bisschen was anderes ist. Und das haben alle Teams gehabt. Schalke und Werder Bremen waren letzte Saison, haben sie beide für ihre Verhältnisse eigentlich fast eine Hinrunde zum Vergessen gespielt. Und diese Probleme hätte ich jetzt bei Bielefeld und Führert auch ausgemacht zu Beginn. Also nach drei, vier Spielen konnte man auch sagen, ja das ist dieses typische Anpassungsproblem. Jetzt inzwischen sind sie ja glaube ich die schlechtesten Absteiger aus der ersten Liga seit Jahren. Und ich habe die Statistik auch schmerzhaft mitbekommen, weil sie sind die schlechtesten Absteiger seit dem FC St. Pauli 2002, 2003. Da ist St. Pauli nämlich dann direkt weiter durchgereicht worden in die dritte Liga. Ich finde die Herangehensweisen auch interessant, weil sie beide unterschiedlich sind. Rashida Sousi da in Fürth hält das, was er da auch gewählt hat, an Worten stark am Trainer fest, während da in Bielefeld schon ziemlich schnell die Reißleine gezogen wird. Und so richtig was gebracht hat es in Bielefeld noch nicht. Was Spielkultur angeht, da ist Fürth tatsächlich ein Team, bei dem ich sagen würde, die versuchen auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge, aber es funktioniert momentan relativ wenig. Da kann ich gar nicht sagen, wo da irgendwie personell vielleicht was fehlt. Vielleicht ist auch eine Idee der Spielidee oder ein Problem der Spielidee, dass da noch nicht ein Rad ins andere läuft. Personell würde man sie oder würde ich sie da unten auf jeden Fall nicht verorten. Das gilt aber für Bielefeld ganz genauso und für Nürnberg auch und für den FC St. Pauli auch. Stehen trotzdem alle unten.
Na, na, na, na. Du geh mal wieder an die Sonne, tank ein bisschen D12, dann bist du wieder ein bisschen positiver. Das kann ja gerade nicht so positiv sein bei dir. Es ist natürlich keine schöne Situation. Platz 17 und 18 für Fürth und für Bielefeld. Aber punktetechnisch ist noch alles drin. Ich finde das interessant und bin dir dankbar, Tim, dass du diesen Punkt nochmal aufgemacht hast. Anpassungsschwierigkeiten haben wir schon häufig gesehen und in unterschiedlicher Güteklasse. Natürlich kann man da dann auch die Reißleine ziehen, wenn man das Gefühl hat, ein Trainer selbst kann mit diesen Anpassungsproblemen nicht umgehen, die auch ein ganzes Team für sich hat. Aber man kann eben auch durchaus in der Vergangenheit sehen, dass man da das Ruder herumreißen kann, auch wenn es jetzt eine Floskel ist und auch wenn das schmerzhafte Anpassungsmomente sind. Aber auch da, wir haben eine lange Winterpause, die auch die 2. Liga betrifft, da gibt es ja die Möglichkeit dann durchaus zu reagieren. Ich rechne eigentlich fest damit, dass die Rückrunde noch weniger vergleichbar zur Hinrente sein wird als sonst in der Liga. Und es betrifft ja auch Bielefeld. Wir sind jetzt auch direkt auch schon im Bielefeld-Bereich dann gelandet. Fadi, welche Unterschiede würdest du denn jetzt zwischen Fürth und Bielefeld sehen? Also Tim hat ja gerade schon ein paar aufgemacht. Unter anderem eben, dass man am einen Standort, nämlich Bielefeld, nicht am Trainer festgehalten hat. Kurz sah es ja auch so aus, als hätte man damit eine super Entscheidung getroffen. Jetzt jüngst aber dann doch nicht mehr so positiv alles bei der Armenia.
Also das wirklich nur sehr, sehr aus der Ferne beurteilt. Aber ich glaube, dass tatsächlich in Bielefeld die Panik nochmal einiges größer ist als in Fürth. Ich habe am Wochenende jetzt ein kurzes Interview mit Sami Arabi gesehen. Dagegen raschete der Susi das blühende Leben. Das sah nicht mehr so ganz souverän aus in Bielefeld. Andererseits haben die ersten Ergebnisse, wie du sagst, nach diesem Trainerwechsel tatsächlich eher schon für sie gesprochen und für diesen Schritt.
Grundsätzlich ist es ja so, dass man schon unterscheiden muss zwischen Bielefeld und Fürth. Allein schon, wie sie in die 1. Liga gekommen sind. Bielefeld war ja auch schon ein Jahr länger in der 1. Liga. Was den Kader angeht, auch was Kaderqualität angeht, war schon eine ganze Ecke weiter als Fürth. Fürth ist ja im Grunde der Aufstiegskader, war ja nur noch zur Hälfte da, als sie in der 1. Liga gespielt haben. Das muss man ja auch mal ganz rational betrachten, dass Greuther Fürth fast ein bisschen chancenlos gewesen ist und jetzt im Grunde ja wirklich ganz bei Null anfängt, während in Bielefeld ja schon super viele Abgänge. Ich will das auch gar nicht schönreden, aber schon so ein bisschen versucht wurde, da auch einiges an Qualität zu halten bzw. das Level zu halten. Und da die Ansprüche vielleicht auch schon noch so ein bisschen andere waren als bei Fürth. Ich meine, ich glaube nicht, dass irgendwo an einem der beiden Standorte gesagt wurde, wir wollen direkt wieder aufsteigen. Aber ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass so in Bielefeld strukturell vielleicht so ein bisschen mehr die Hoffnung da ist, dass man ein bisschen besser in die Saison startet. Grundsätzlich ist es aber natürlich so, man muss ja auch sagen, auch Schalke und Werder haben innerhalb der letzten Saison den Trainer gewechselt und hatten diese Anpassungsprobleme. Und ich wiederhole mich da gerne. Also ich glaube, in der zweiten Liga ist es, wenn du da erstmal in so einen Lauf reinkommst, erstmal zwei, drei Spiele gewinnst, den Negativlauf kannst du halt auch haben, da kannst du auch reinkommen. Aber dann geht das relativ fix. Und jetzt können wir den Bogen wieder zum Anfang der Sendung schlagen, weil jetzt ist der HSV relativ weit vorne, aber aufgestiegen sind sie eben noch nicht. Und das Frühjahr zeigt ja dann tatsächlich doch immer wieder, dass der HSV ja vielleicht dann doch nochmal ein paar Probleme bekommt und andere Teams da doch sehr viel näher ranrücken können, als es jetzt zum Beispiel gerade aktuell aussieht. Und St. Pauli war letzte Saison auch so unfassbar weit vorne und hat glaube ich in der Rückrunde irgendwie 13 Punkte allein auf Schalke 04 verloren. Also so unfassbare Zahlen. Und da kann also noch viel gehen und ich glaube persönlich nicht, dass das für Fürth und Bielefeld gerade was so Abstieg angeht, dass das nochmal ein Thema wird bei denen. Ich glaube, die werden sich irgendwie da wieder ranziehen. Muss aber auch ehrlich sagen, und da muss ich dann vielleicht deinem Kollegen, dem werten Herrn Fischer ein bisschen beiflichten, wenn eins der beiden Teams größere Probleme bekommt, dann dürfte es Kreuter Fürth sein.
Na, mit dieser positiven Note.
Ja, ich bin begeistert, dass Tim das noch geschafft hat, trotz meiner Bemühungen hier schlechte Laune zu verbreiten. Und dann gehen wir hier positiv gestimmt aus dem Podcast raus. Das ist sensationell.
Naja, nicht alle, glaube ich, positiv gestimmt. Aber ich meine, da wird es dann, vielleicht mache ich wirklich diesen Kurzpass, den es ja eigentlich geben muss. Also Eva und Michi Fischer, Eva Lottabole und Michi Fischer, die sind ja Stammbesetzung schon in der Erstligasaison gewesen im letzten Jahr. Vielleicht muss ich das einfach im Kurzpass nochmal rausholen als Weihnachtsgeschenk dann irgendwie am Ende dieser Hinrunde. War jetzt eigentlich gar nicht so geplant, aber vielleicht lohnt da nochmal ein näherer Blick hin. Ich bin euch beiden aber sehr dankbar, dass ihr euch jetzt die Zeit genommen habt, so genau auf so viele Teams zu blicken. Und eben nicht nur auf eure so genau. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank. Das hat große Freude gemacht. Ich denke auch den Hörern und Hörern, die auch bemerkt haben jetzt aktuell auch auf das zweite Feedback wird und euch bin ich gleich eingegangen. Das zweite Feedback von euch nach dem letzten Kurzpass war nämlich Länge des Kurzpasses ist uns – ich sag's einfach mal – scheißegal und dementsprechend habe ich das jetzt auch hier einfach laufen lassen. Ganz herzlichen Dank, dass ich das tun durfte. An Tim Ecksteen vom Millern-Ton. Folgt ihm alle als Tim-Ecksteen auf Twitter. Tim, danke dir, dass du dich mal wieder durch Statistiken gewöhnt hast, dir 1000 Tabs aufgeöffnet hast. Wahrscheinlich allein für diese Aufnahme hat wieder große Freude gemacht, dich hier im Rasenfunk zu haben.
Ja, sehr gern. Hat mich auch sehr gefreut.
Das ist schön zu hören. Und ganz herzlichen Dank auch an Fadi Keblawi von den Nürnberger Nachrichten und natürlich dem Fußballpodcast. Kadeb, der AtGoPunkHurst auf Twitter. Danke dir, Fadi, ein grandioses Rasenfunk-Debüt. Du hast hier, obwohl du es anders proklamiert hast, gute Laune reingebracht, finde ich zumindest.
Tatsächlich, das freut mich sehr.
Sehr gerne, kommen gerne wieder und euch lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Es gibt im Rasenfunk noch eine ganze Reihe von anderen Sendungen, die ihr euch anhören könntet. Wir haben ein Tribüngespräch zum Beispiel aufgenommen zum Missbrauchsskandal in der NWSL. Und natürlich machen wir auch Sendungen zur Frauen-Bundesliga und zur 1. Bundesliga der Männer. Klickt euch einfach mal ein bisschen rum auf rasenfunk.de und dann hören wir uns hoffentlich bald hier wieder. Bis dahin bleibt gesund, macht es gut und unterstützt uns gerne, wenn ihr mögt. Bis bald wieder hier im Rasenfunk.